[Musique]
pierre que le ca bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle think ur view nous sommes
en direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
je suis actuellement retraité c'est ma
fonction la plus stable et pour le reste
j'ai écrit avec expérience
professionnelle que j'ai eu c'est à dire
sur les questions stratégiques et d'une
manière générale sur les questions de
société qui me paraissent les plus
intéressantes
j'essaye d'être sur des sujets qui ne
sont pas exploré par les autres parce
que je suis ni chercheurs ni décideurs
et donc je suis totalement libre de
définir ce que gervais
est donc là j'ai fait ou de bouquins sur
les radicalisme religieux
qui s'appelle avec du on discute pas on
ne reviendra sur les plages bien en
sortir un autre sur le lobby saoudien en
france qui paradoxalement n'a fait
l'objet d'aucune étude alors que ses
effets sont remarquables voilà pour
l'essentiel alors on va commencer sur le
lobby saoudiens et les radicalisme
religieux puis ensuite on va délier un
petit peu sur les tensions qui se passe
actuellement
dans l'âge et aux pratiques d'un
géopolitique mondiale et sur l'échiquier
mondial le radicalisme religieux en
france ça représente un danger pas un
danger est-ce que c'est contrôlable est
ce que les autorités publiques ont pris
réellement conscience de la chose autre
que du traitement symptomatique
d'abord moi j'aurais faire un espèce de
plans larges c'est à dire que ce qui m'a
intéressé c'est les radicalisme
religieux et le sous titre du bouquin
d'ailleurs ça s'appelle d islamiser le
débat pourquoi parce que ce qui me
frappe c'est que nos évidemment on a de
bonnes raisons de se préoccuper du
radicalisme salafistes djihadistes mais
d'abord ça n'est pas la seule forme de
radicalisme et d'autre part les autres
radicalisme par exemple le néo
évangéliques américains quand ils
soutiennent une guerre en irak c'est pas
parce que les agréger les irakiens sont
bombardés par des bombes plus tôt par
des attentats que ça change la nature de
la légitimation de la violence quand
c'est une violence d'état elle n'est pas
plus légitime quand c'est une violence
terroriste et donc je suis parti sur
cette idée c'est à dire finalement
quelles sont les grandes guerres
religieuses qui sont touchés aujourd'hui
par cette fonction dans les années 60 70
70 80 tout le monde qu'on diagnostique
un retour du religieux moi ce que je
constate c'est surtout une avancée des
radicalismes c'est à dire de gens qui
légitime la violence légitime la
violence pour des raisons théologiques
et donc j'ai essayé de creuser un peu
dans toutes les directions c'est à dire
le les évangéliques américains les
déloger des américains les juifs
radicaux évidemment les salafistes
djihadistes mais j'ai découvert avec
surprise aussi que le bouddhisme et
l'hindouisme et est aussi frappé par la
radicalisation a survolé le bouddhisme
étant le cas le plus intéressant parce
que comme pour nous le bouddhisme c'est
le dalaï lama et le matthieu ricard en
fait on s'aperçoit que les bouddhistes
non seulement eu des phases de violence
extrêmement importante mais qu' on le
voit bien en libye remaniée aujourd'hui
les rohingya sont les pauvres types si
vous voulez acquis le birmanie
indépendante a refusé la nationalité
donc c'était des apatrides et quand il
ya des poussées de fièvre parfois
instrumentalisée par des moines comme
vire à tous le célèbre pirate ou sur
lequel barbet schroeder avait fait un
film ces types ont des discours qu'on
pourrait entendre dans la bouche des
prédicateurs salafistes d'arabie
saoudite mois et donc paradoxalement ça
met en question un point qui arrive qui
faisait consensus chez les chercheurs
c'est qu'on disait que c'était le
monothéisme qu'ils étaient par nature
intolérant malheureusement le club s'est
élargi et on voit bien en inde
aujourd'hui qu'il ya au pouvoir un type
bodies narendra modi qui a été élu par
un parti qui justement mais la défense
de l'hindouisme c'est à dire en gros la
ségrégation des musulmans comme seule
île de conduite
donc c'est de même intéressé à tout ça
et de comprendre pourquoi ces processus
ont été concomitant voilà c'est donc ça
la démarche de départ donc pour les
français quand je dis d islamiser le
débat ça veut dire faites attention au
fait que en fait c'est un domaine qui
touche à beaucoup d'air que bert
religieuse et donc moi évidemment comme
tout français je suis surtout préoccupé
par les dérives violentes du salafisme
mais que ce salafisme et c'est radical
il fonctionne en miroir c'est à dire que
évidemment chacun des deux trouve sa
légitimité de la violence de l'autre
prend un exemple qui volontairement hors
de france quand les talibans ont détruit
les
les bouddhas de bamyan cc boude
absolument fantastique moi j'ai eu la
chance de les voir avant qu'ils soient
détruits qui étaient des bouddhas taillé
dans la falaise qui faisait 50 60 mètres
de haut
c'était des bouddhistes parce que en
fait ben y'en a été avait été dans le
temps avant la conquête musulmane un
grand centre de bouddhistes et quand on
voit d'ailleurs tous ces trous dans la
falaise c'était des chambres de moine
c'était il ya tout un réseau de
circulation dans la falaise pour et
paradoxalement cette destruction des
bouddhas de bamyan chez nous est restée
sur le plan culturel mais chez les
bouddhistes c'est considéré comme une
agression musulmane et quand je vous le
transpose la discussion sur la birmanie
c'est le myanmar l'a effectivement il
avait à portée de la main si vous voulez
les gens auxquels ils allaient faire
porter la responsabilité de cette
radicalisation donc tous ces choses-là
fonction d'un miroir et donc city est
intéressant c'est de les voir comme une
totalité et pas comme une somme de fait
séparés
alors
qu est ce qui ressort un peu tout ça
d'abord le fait que tous ces mouvements
naissent à l'articulation du 19e et du
20e siècle ce qui a le plus traumatisé
les
religions les grandes religions de la
planète ça a été le darwinisme parce que
darwin arriver à prouver que l'homme
avait pas d'origine divine qui
descendait du singe ça fait désordre
dans une théologie et donc il ya eu
toute une époque où les progrès de la
science et de la connaissance en ont
secoué les théologies bon et puis il ya
un deuxième chose c'est cuvier
c'est-à-dire cuvier qui commencent à
ressortir bm des ossuaires d'animaux qui
ont existé avant la création de l'homme
bon donc comme disait l'autre qu'est ce
que faisait dieu avant la création de
l'homme quoi donc toutes ces théologie
se sont trouvés secoué évidemment
d'autant plus secoués qu'elles se sont
parfois surajouter à la colonisation
c'est avec la colonisation est venu en
plus tentés d'imposer la religion
quelque illégitime et sa propre
conquêtes coloniales sur les populations
indigènes
donc tout ça a contribué à faire
apparaître une espèce de crispation
religieuses en particulier chez les pays
colonisés qui se disait mais après tout
notre identité c'est pas celle là dedans
alors il ya un cas qui est très
intéressant c'est le cas de l'inde parce
que
autant tout on connait gandhi l'homme de
la non-violence et serra de la
désobéissance civile et idra ce qu'on
connaît moins bien c'est un autre
penseur qui s'appelle savoir car qui
écrivait à la fin du 19e siècle début du
xxème un bouquin qui s'appelle jean do i
qui est un doux et il montre et il
voulait montrer par là que le sous
continent y compris le pakistan et même
le parti du bangladesh était en fait une
terre un doux et c'est à dire que tous
les gens qui étaient là étaient en fait
des occupants un dut alors il refait un
retour en flash back sur l'histoire en
expliquant que justement l'oppression
des indo est consécutive à la 7 siècles
d'occupation musulmane donc il a tout de
suite la désignation de de la population
responsable de ça plus évidemment la
colonisation mais il se focalise sur les
hindous et donc le mouvement
indépendantiste indien va être divisé en
deux idéologies une qui est celle de
gandhi qui vatry finalement triompher
puisqu'ils vont le prendre comme
interlocuteur 20 pour la dépendance mais
il est resté ce
parti politique celui de savoir car et
qu'il y avait en particulier ces
organisations de jeunesse qui
ressemblait beaucoup au jeunesse
fasciste et qui eux étaient pour
l'adepte du nouvion d'une indépendance
violente et le moment paroxystique de
tout ça c'est au moment de
l'indépendance et en 47 quand gandil le
héros de l'indépendance va être
assassiné par un disciple de savoir car
götze et qui est un type qui justement
appartenait à ces organisations de
jeunesse relevant deux du parti radical
du parti en tout cas pour une
indépendance violente et qui va donc
assassiné l'homme de paix qui est dit et
ça c'est une autre caractéristique de
ces radicalisme religieux dans l'ordre
des ennemis pour eux le pire c'est
l'homme de paix c'est à dire celui qui
est de la même religion mais qui ne
n'adoptent pas cette ligue mais on en a
d'autres exemples contient les
négociations entre sadate et rabin si
vous voulez sur le
pour le premier première reconnaissance
d'israël par un pays arabe chacun des
deux leaders va être assassiné par
radical de son propre camp c'est à dire
ça date va être assassiné par un frère
musulman et rabin a été assassiné par un
radical religieux juifs qui le
considèrent comme un traître
donc si chacun de ses deux pouces et
radicalisme sont en fait des moments
historiques sur lesquels on avait une
lecture
qu'on considérait comme circonstanciel
et non pas comme un mouvement de fond
est donc aujourd'hui on est en plein
face au problème puisqu'on s'aperçoit
que même dans un pays comme l'inde
depuis qu arrive au bout au pouvoir un
type donc on arrête drame audi qui a
fait de son de la direction de son point
politique justement la ségrégation
contre les musulmans alors deux ou trois
exemples pour vous donner une idée de ce
qu'est cette politique ségrégationniste
les radicaux du bjp ont inventé
alors le bjp c'est le nom du parti je le
dis pas on y dit parce que je ne connais
pas mais c'est le parti qui a porté donc
maudit au pouvoir et par exemple ils ont
la guerre de la vache le gars de la
vache sa part du principe que dans la
religion hindoue la bâche étant sacrée
il devrait pas y avoir de boucherie or
les bushmen sont tenues évidemment par
les musulmans ou par des chrétiens par
des animistes donc à partir de là ce
sont des personnes qui violent la loi un
doux et comme la terre est un double à
ce moment les attaques des boucheries
éventuellement et une bouche etc
il y avait un autre qui est beaucoup
plus paroxystique et peut-être encore
plus cocasse
c'est un programme qui s'appelle le lof
jihad l'original ça veut dire que ces
radicaux prétendent que de jeunes
musulmans sont mandatés pour séduire de
jeunes filles hindouistes et ensuite de
les convertir à l'islam et donc ils ont
fait passer une loi au parlement indien
qui autorise les parents à demander la
dissolution du mariage
peut pas penser texte fut
ségrégationniste que celui là en
birmanie je reste volontairement sur des
religions monopoly thijs parce qu'encore
une fois il faut sortir de l'idée que
seul le monothéisme ne fera que par ça
en birmanie donc en peu de mots
l'histoire de ce héros ignace et c'est
absolument dramatique parce que ce sont
des populations que les anglais à
l'époque de la colonisation ont pris au
bangladesh qui les ont fait venir pour
travailler sur les plantations de thé en
birmanie et donc au moment de
l'indépendance de la birmanie les biomes
on dit ces gens là sont pas de chez nous
donc il dort de même pas la nationalité
donc ça va être des apatrides
ces apatrides bon bain et les tolère
mais avec des poussées de fièvre
régulière et dans les dernières lois
votées par ces moines bouddhistes qui
évidemment pousse à la poussent à la
roue en matière d'intolérance il ya
l'obligation pour les femmes moyenne il
ya l'interdiction pour les femmes de
l'illiade à voir plus d'un enfant avec
un à ces interstices de temps qui doit
être de 18 20 ou 24 mois j'en sais rien
c'est à dire pour limiter la natalité
chez les rohingya et puis des lois comme
ça donc toutes ces choses là un montre
qu' on a un phénomène qui évidemment
partout et du et d'une grande de
intolérance à l'égard de la minorité
pour te donner une idée on mène la
minorité musulmane c'est quand même 190
millions de personnes donc c'est quand
même une petite grosse minorité quoi et
voilà donc le pour rester juste sur le
cas de l'inde la raison pour laquelle
les disciples de savard car envol à
gandhi c'est que gandhi à accepter
l'existence du pakistan et pour eux
c'est donc la tradition puisque tous et
radicalisme ont une espèce de
géopolitique rêver cette géopolitique
rêver c'est quelle est la carte légitime
de notre emprise religieuse donc par
exemple sur le site du parti politique
du bjp donc du parti de narendra modi il
ya une carte qui va de l'afghanistan
jusqu'à la birmanie et qui disent l'ère
du woudy l'heure de la douche c'est ça
donc en gros il nie l'existence du
pakistan il nie l'existence du
l'afghanistan et même une partie de la
birmanie donc chacun de ces veilles plus
pareil les la carte du grand israël si
tu veux quand tu le regardes sur les
sites religieux
c'est pas la peine de développer mais
enfin on se rend bien compte que il ya
par exemple rabbin dont j'ai oublié le
nom
qui dit une phrase que je trouve très
symbolique qui disait
il ya aucune raison que de rétrocéder le
moindre centimètre carré de cette terre
qui nous a été donnée par dieu pour
entamer une négociation avec les
palestiniens c'est bien parti donc il ya
toujours cette idée chez les religieux
juifs en particulier radicaux que le
quand israël n'est toujours pas
construit chez les ans et s'est vengé
lis qu'on retrouve la même problématique
c'est à dire la constitution du grand
israël et une étape absolument
indispensable au retour du messie
alors une fois il y avait une discussion
alors donc ces évangéliques sont des
prêts les soutiens les plus fermes de
d'israël est évidemment de netanyahou
est alors une fois il ya une discussion
assez amusante entre des représentants
des évangéliques américains qui étaient
en israël et avec netanyahu et alors
vous savez que pour les juifs donc le
messie n'est jamais arrivé pour les
chrétiens il déjà arrivé moi et donc
comme tout ça est une espèce de
discussions comment dire de
proximité stratégique il ya quand même
ces divergences théologiques alors le
pour les évangéliques
la constitution de grands israël est un
étape indispensable au retour du messie
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
ils ont soutenu la guerre d'irak parce
que l'imaginaire vous priver de quelque
chose plus pardon pardon vous avez un
ami imaginaire non j'ai un ennemi
universel qui est la connerie comme
disait le proverbe guatémaltèque c'est
la mer connerie est perpétuellement
enceinte parce que quand on a fait le
tour de la planète sur un sujet comme
celui là c'est un peu préoccupant une
remarque quand même c'est que ces
radicalisme religieux sont des pratiques
religieuses sans hiérarchie
ce qui freine particulier les chrétiens
catholiques romains etc et les
orthodoxes mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ça laisse la place à ce qu'on
a vu fleurir absolument partout c'est à
dire le prédicateur qui dit moi j'ai le
contact direct avec dieu et je vais vous
donner la bonne interprétation de la
religion dont vous l'avez chez les
salafistes djihadistes ont lâché les gv
angélique américain où elle a des
prédicateurs qui arrivent sont les
premiers avoir fait un discours qui qui
couvrait la planète avec les moyens de
télévisuelle puis ensuite avec internet
et on a donc ce phénomène qui est un
phénomène de houchin type ce mandat tout
seul pour dire moi j'ai eu un contact
avec dieu j'ai la bonne pratique et donc
je vais vous dire comment il faut faire
donc si radicale ils sont un phénomène
qui a présentent des caractéristiques
sociologiques et évidemment stratégique
commune et donc on est bon pour un
certain nombre de conflits dans lesquels
effectivement on verra des massacres et
cie banque ce qui évidemment pose un
problème excuse moi je te mets là dessus
mais ce qui pose un problème sur le
droit d'intervention des puissances
occidentales dans ce genre de débat
c'est à dire est ce qu'on va aller
séparer les sunnites et les chiites est
ce qu'on va les séparer les évangéliques
et les irakiens rappelle toi que chirac
dit la guerre d'irak est une bêtise or
il y avait parmi les motivations de
bouche cette soutient que coffret les
évangéliques vous n'oublierez pardon ce
gros lobby derrière lui un gros lobby
pied alors ce qui est rigolo c'est que
cela bla bases théologiques des
évangéliques c'est de dire donc saddam
hussein c'est le nouveau nabuchodonosor
donc sa disparition va permettre la
constitution du grand israël à la
constitution du grand israël va
permettre à ce moment là le retour du
messie le retour du messie se traduira
par la conversion universel donc ça veut
dire que même le grand israël se
convertirait à la au christianisme alors
j'en termine juste sur cette anecdote
parce que les rigolote donc netanyahu
discutant avec les évangéliques qu'ils
avaient cette divergences théologiques
importante c'est est-ce que c'était le
retour du messie ou est-ce que c'était
l'arrivée du messie et netanyahu pour en
sortir parce qu'il voulait garder le
soutien des évangéliques le d'écouter le
jour où le messie arrivera on lui posera
une seule question est ce que c'est la
première fois où ce que c'est la
deuxième fois que tu viens donc voilà on
en est à ce débat cette ce genre de
discussions pour arriver à prendre
conciliables des principes écologiques
qui ne sont pas du tout premier première
question
cette accélération du quine du
radicalisme c'est quoi c'est parce que
c'est un business
ce business dans
certaines tranches est en train de
perdre des parts de marché
et donc les prédicateurs sentent que
leur influence est en train de baisser
dont qui monte en puissance en termes de
dureté de leur discours de côté hyper
acide pour galvaniser leurs fidèles ou
c'est parce que la situation économique
amène des âmes en errance beaucoup plus
facilement donc ça les laisse on va dire
faible à toute l'équipe de propagande
religieuse les webséries nation
effectivement c'est une question
importante et laquelle il est très
difficile de répondre parce que même
s'ils se radicaliseront tous cette
poussée extraordinaire avec les
traductions de violences de toutes les
formes que ça va adopter depuis
l'attentât terroriste jusqu'aux
bombardements
il ya un mélange à la fois de cause
génériques et de cause particulière par
exemple tu vois bien que les
évangéliques par exemple sont des gens
qui avec trump trump a constitué un
conseil évangélique autour de lui avec
tous les gens qui avaient approuvé la
guerre d'irak donc on boucle avec bush
qui voit qui lui même était un reborn
christiane pour aller faire la guerre al
qaïda à ben laden qui était un ruban de
muslim c'est-à-dire ce phénomène tu vois
de ces gens qui adhèrent à cette
pratique religieuse c'est que tout à
coup cette conversion recevra ce
radicalisme et une conversion qui marque
une nouvelle naissance et donc tu as tu
avais avec trump l'idée qu'il fallait
bien s'appuyer sur cette tendance qui
évidemment représente quand même
quelques centaines de milliers de
personnes dans
11 états unis donc une soutient
effectivement qu'il a gardé jusqu'au
bout c'est à dire que le personnage
pouvait être un type marié trois fois
qu'ils pensaient les fesses des femmes
etc mais on voit bien que le principe de
son action était approuvée par des mecs
qui aurait condamné cette attitude
vis-à-vis de n'importe quel autre à
tunis pour des doutes quand
oui mais en même temps tu vois bien que
dans le cas de l'islam on a
effectivement un phénomène qui prend sa
naissance sous la colonisation et donc
qui va commencer avec l'apparition des
frères musulmans
et puis qui ensuite sous l'action
notamment de la diplomation religieuse
de l'arabie saoudite va se transformer
en salafisme c'est à dire des gens qui
disent
la seule bonne période de notre histoire
c'était l'époque des salaf des
compagnons du prophète et c'était la
seule véritable comment dire pratique
religieuse acceptable pourquoi ces
sorties d'arabie saoudite pour une
raison très simple c'est que l'arabie
saoudite n'a jamais été colonisé c'est à
dire la partie centrale le jazz le grand
désert du centre n'a jamais été colonisé
les turcs occupé effectivement la borne
ouest où il y avait les lieux saints et
puis les anglais ont commencé à
coloniser sur la côte est et en
particulier le koweït enfin bref
intéressé par le pétrole les autres
intéressés par l' empire ottoman empire
ottoman sur la maîtrise des lieux saints
et donc tous ces gens qui étaient dans
le centre de l'arabie saoudite d'où va
paraître le prédicateur abdel wahab
c'est des gens qu'ils m'attendent
elissalde s'est perverti quand il a
quitté l'afrique donc le seul véritable
islam celle notre treizième siècle
pardon c'est celui du xiiie siècle non
c'est celui du xviie qui va
effectivement être captées si tu veux
par in saud bin abdelaziz saoud le
fondateur de la dynastie qui va bien
comprendre l'intérêt qu'il y à pouvoir
tenir ce discours delà du radicalisme
religieux surtout qui sait il va
affronter des ottomans sur la côte est
et il va affronter des anglais sur la
côte ouest donc on est encore dans une
époque où le salafisme enfin le
wahhabisme situe aussi pour le reprendre
dans son dans la filiation
le le wahhabisme est encore une espèce
de pratique minoritaire de l'islam
pourquoi parce que les saoud ne sont pas
des descendants du prophète et donc il
leur faut une légitimité religieuse qui
va leur être données par ces
prédicateurs qui vont dire le seul
véritable islam celle d'autres et
rappelez vous que quand on a cet épisode
de lawrence d'arabie c'est à dire quand
et anglais pensent utiliser
effectivement le nationalisme arabe pour
chasser les ottomans le
lawrence d'arabie négocié avec le chérif
de la mecque qui est en fait un des
descendants du prophète donc pour lui la
création de la grande nation arabe se
ferait avec un espèce de discipline
religieuse qui procurait sa filiation
avec le prophète mais en fait bon les
anglais
grand une grande colonisateur décide que
finalement la nation arabe ce sera pas
pour cette fois ci et donc qu'ils vont
laisser dans un profond désarroi laisser
les gens qui avaient la légitimité et ça
va être la conquête des lieux saints par
de résine daoud et puis évidemment avec
la pratique du web if qui va s'implanter
sur la région d le sien est par contre
en lot de compensation les anglais vont
défiler la jordanie et la syrie aux
descendants du chérif de la mecque donc
on est sur une carte où les musulmans
ont de bonnes raisons si tu veux te
considérer que effectivement ce désarroi
quand représenter la colonisation cette
trahison etc va se traduire par
l'affirmation d'une identité musulmane
qui en gros avec les frères musulmans 17
à 12 nous occuper de nos progrès à faire
la radicalisation responsables métiers à
chacune des ces variables a
effectivement une composante coloniale
et en même temps une composante
nationale quoi je je je lis un
commentaire une question de gazole selon
l'écrivain amin malouf dans son livre le
naufrage des civilisations l'état
saoudien a misé dans la deuxième moitié
du xxème siècle sur le nationalisme pour
souder unir cimenter la population c'est
l'effet contraire qui est apparue de
points le peuple s'est retrouvé
fragmenté pierre conesa partage-t-il ce
point de vue comment expliquer ce
phénomène paradoxal
mais amin maalouf ne s'intéresse pas
qu'à l'état saoudien il parle de
l'ensemble de la comment le dire delà de
l'identité arabo musulmane
est effectivement par exemple si on
prend le cas du califat requis est une
grande contre le grand thème de
propagande que utiliser l'état islamique
récemment le califat est supprimée par
atatürk c'est à dire que le khalife
était déjà un turc et ses peintures qui
supprime cette institution qui existe
pratiquement depuis la fin la mort du
prophète donc on a quelque chose si tu
veux ou on a à la fois des amis et des
ennemis dans la même aire culturelle que
l'arabie saoudite dans sa diplomatie
religieuse
faut l'avoir en plusieurs étapes
première étape constitue le royaume
d'arabie saoudite
sur la carte de la planète on sort de la
guerre de 14-18 et en 1923 qui va
s'occuper de ce qui se passe dans ce
morceau de désert donc c'est un espèce
de nains politiques et religieux ce que
personne ne va je pense et à traiter si
tu veux la seule chose avec laquelle on
estimé dean de comment dire de trancher
vos cours des des traités de versailles
locarno etc c'est de dire bon comment
est-ce qu'on partage l'empiré ottoman
donc le partage de l'empiré ottoman
c'est les anglais qui vont prendre
effectivement l'irak intéressé par le
pétrole les français vont prendre la
syrie le liban et puis ensuite on va
faire cette répartition des couronnes
que je vous ai expliqué c'est à dire
qu'en gros les choses se décident
adversaires
ce qui va se passer à partir des années
60 et en particulier appartement où ils
73 quand ils verront le boom pétrolier
s'est d'abord deux choses les années 60
c'est l'apparition du socialisme arabe
le socialisme arabe le grand leader
c'est nacer bennacer dit tout simplement
il dit les arabo lui s'occupait d'israël
ferait mieux de s'occuper des pays du
golfe en gros il ya du pognon il ya deux
là il ya du pétrole ces termes donc pour
les saoudiens deux choses d'abord
l'ennemi c'est nasser et c'est le
socialisme arabe c'est une des raisons
si tu veux pour lesquels ils ont
combattu contre saddam contre la sadc
mais en plus
dans le champ de l'est ouest les
américains et les occidentaux
considèrent que la religion est un
véritable barrière contre le communisme
qui lui pratiquer un athéisme actifs et
donc ils disent bon ben il faut
s'appuyer sur les pays religieux pour
contrer l'influencé des socialistes et
des communistes mans est donc le premier
axe de développement de la diplomatie
religieuse de l'arabie saoudite ça va
pas du tout être en europe ça va être
pour empêcher la diffusion du socialisme
arabe en afrique et donc l'essentiel de
ces jeunes qui vont attirer à
l'université islamique de médine c'est
pour porter une politique anti
nassérienne quelques exemples quand
nasser constitue la ligue arabe les
saoudiens continue la ligue islamique
mondiale donc tu vois c'est pas le même
champ géographique
l'université la plus réputée de cette
époque c'est l'université al azhar et
qui attirait effectivement déjà des
étudiants en théologie mais avec le
niveau de vie de l'egypte
il a tiré ce qu'ils pouvaient par contre
les aoûtiens créé l'université islamique
de médine et là ils promettent aux
jeunes d'avoir une peau d'ours d'avoir
une chambre et ses dons qu'ils attirent
le flux vers eux et on estime que les
saoudiens donc dans une période qui doit
s'étendre depuis les années 50 jusqu'à
1980 ils ont formé à peu près trente
mille mec 30000 type alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en dans le contrat
de bourse il leur était imposé de
retourner faire de la prédication et ne
pouvait pas demander la nationalité
saoudienne enfin pas déconner quoi on
repart et donc un de ces types qui est
très intéressant qui occupe aujourd'hui
le champ de l'actualité c'est le patron
des musulmans du mali mahmoud dicko qui
est un type qui a été formé à médine et
c'est un type qui a refusé de condamner
l'attentât terroriste contre le radisson
blu dans lequel des occidentaux ont été
tués parce que pour lui c'est soit
l'explication c'est la faute de la
colonisation soit c'est la faute des
mécréants donc tu vois cette influence
là est une influence qui s'est faite par
morceaux avec une certaine efficacité
site de l'université islamique de médine
c'est comme le sait comme l'université
lumumba à moscou c'est à dire on faisait
venir des cas dont les renvoyer puis
devait ensuite faire la prédication donc
le tout ce phénomène là ça dépasse là qu
on s'intéresse quant à l'époque on
pensait que le grand ennemi c'était
nasser on voit bien qu effectivement les
critères de l'analyse si tu veux
consistait à considérer que l'arabie
saoudite était un allié alors il va y
avoir une époque où si tu veulent toutes
les caractéristiques du système vont
soit être renforcée soit changée 79
l'année 79 est une année cruciale parce
que février c'est la révolution
islamique à téhéran teheran ça veut dire
que non seulement au milieu d'année
depuis la révolution islamique à téhéran
s'est tout à coup un dignitaire chiite
qui dit le véritable leader de l'islam
c'est moi à dire ça ou ça vous dire
alors qu'ils les iraniens et qu'il est
chiite je veux dire on ne pouvait pas
poser un postulat a plus de perte de
marché oui mais c'est à dire que ce qui
est amusant c'est que donc il va pousser
au pèlerinage sur les lieux saints et
que quand les contingents iranien arrive
dans le pèlerinage il passe devant le
mont arafat et le monde théoriquement
symbolise le diable mais dans les actes
et la théologie
dans la géopolitique iranienne de
khomeiny le diable c'était le petit
démon c'était israël est grande et mons
et les etats-unis dans quand les mecs
lancé des pierres sur le mort a enfin
dit crié à bas les états unis ski en
plein centre d'arabie saoudite c'est de
s'imposer quand même quelques problèmes
donc il ya eu quelques mouvements de
foule un peu aidé par la police
saoudienne et où il ya eu 350 morts dans
le tunnel tout est donc une première
étape importante 79 la révolution
iranienne qui va considérablement
déstabiliser le régime c'est la deuxième
époque l'occupation de la grande mosquée
de la mecque par des disciples n'ont pas
de trop mais ni mais par des disciples
du grand mufti saoudien s'appelait une
base parce que lui continué son discours
de la radicalisation en dix ans il le
salafisme le seul véritable pratique de
l'islam est le problème c'est que l'état
où il n'avait pas la légitimité
généalogique parra pose donc là il faut
commencer à fomenter l'idée qu'après
tout les saoud n'étaient pas les plus à
même de piloter cette espèce de croisade
religieuse et donc ce sont des élèves du
grand moufti qui vont occuper la grande
mosquée pendant le pèlerinage alors la
grande mosquée de la mecque ces quatre
minarets avait en plus de cette enceinte
où circulent les croyants et donc les
mecs mettent des tireurs d'élite sur les
quatre mosquées et cfi impossible de
reprendre la grande mosquée parce que
dès que les policiers saoudiens arrive
il a retiré les flingues dessus gros
mouvement de foule enfin tout ce que
vous pouvez imaginer et donc pendant je
crois une trentaine de jours le combo ce
qui est occupé donc les minarets sont
transformés en virades ont absolument et
en même temps c'est un lieu dans lequel
on peut pas déployer la violence par
principe dont petite huile était pas
question de tirer au canon sur les
minarets bon et donc les troupes d'élite
saoudienne essaye de reprendre la
mosquée mais ça tourne en eau de boudin
n'y arrive pas et sait d'où la nécessité
de deux choses d'abord trouver une
explication théologique pour aller
déloger et deuxième chose trouvaient des
forces capables de faire ça alors
l'explication ou légitime tout amène
attendant il faut faire un peu peur pas
un peu preuve quand même de souplesse
intellectuelle donc ils demandent au
fameux une base devrait unir un comptage
en deux
de savants de la religion pour 10
rebonds comment peut-on faire quelle est
la légitimité à utiliser la violence
dans ces lieux saints
alors les types qui avait occupé la
mosquée disait c'était justement d'aider
des plus les plus radicaux des radicaux
ils disaient non la dynastie des saoud
est tout à fait indigne
le retour du messie fera l'éviction de
la dynastie des saoud est d'ailleurs le
messie arrive avec nous c'est mon cousin
il est là parmi le groupe donc l'aigle
et docteurs de la foi se réunissent et
disent attendent à temps là ça se tient
pas debout leurs explications là parce
que c'est vrai que le prophète avait dit
que quand le messie reviendrai mais
quand messi reviendrait il se
débarrasserait des dynasties indignes et
il ferait triompher la vraie foi or les
saoud ne sont pas une dynastie indigne
et corrompu donc le type qui présente
comme le messie ne peut pas être le
messie donc on peut leur rentrée dans
l'eure dans l'art et donc ensuite se
poser la deuxième question c'est à dire
comment fait-on pour faire sortir des
types parce qu'il ya des tas de soute et
reste dans la grande mosquée et donc il
s'adresse et le coup de génie de giscard
et de poniatowski c'est à dire mais
attendez nous on a le gign on a une
troupe d'élite qui est capable de vous
faire ça
donc on envoie la troupe du gign les
mecs convertir 24 heures me bats en 2h
tac tac tac et ils vont piloter
l'opération de pression donc évidemment
ça fait désordre c'est à dire que la
dynastie des saoud fait appel à des
mécréants pour libérer l'espace de la
grande mosquée explique pourquoi
converti en 24 heures parce que tout le
monde n'est pas ou fait tout ce qui se
passe ah ben c'est simple la conversion
dans l'islam se limite à l'âme ce qu'on
appelle la chahada c'est à dire le
premier principe à la il ya là mohamed à
réseau lalla c'est à dire il n'ya qu'un
seul dieu c'est dieu et mahomet est son
prophète donc tu dis ça c'est fini tes
côtés considérés comme musulmans le
mouvement inverse est formellement
interdit libre et donc ces types
converti à l'horizon pas à pénétrer à
proprement parler un bosquet ils ont
piloté la chose était enfin si tu veux
ça faisait désordre dans le paysage
troisième épisode qui va en partie sauvé
les meubles delà de la dynastie saout
c'est l'invasion soviétique en
afghanistan en décembre à partir de ce
moment là on va évacuer tous ces jeunes
turbulents si tu veux on leur dise mais
allez donc pratiquer le jihad contre le
véritable ennemi qu'est le communisme en
aplanissant et c'est vrai que les
saoudiens vont constituer le premier
contingent étranger chez les
moudjahidines afghans
alors vous connaissez tous que ces
moudjahidine là sont des combattants de
la liberté et qualificatifs qu'on a
inventé à washington et qui ont été
répercutées par bhl de nombreuses fois
or qu'on sait très bien que quand ils
ont pris le pouvoir après c'est à dire
quand les talibans sont arrivés c'était
tout sauf des combattants de la liberté
mais combi combattez contre le
communisme ils avaient droit au titre
donc c'est assez intéressant parce que
tu vois comment en fait on projette sur
une situation locale des postulats
idéologique qui sont nés ici dans le
quartier latin c'est à dire quand comme
bhl va avoir massoud le chef il il
oublie de dire que c'est un tadjik
population minorité en afghanistan et
que le célèbre massoud situent eux qui
évidemment occupe une position
importante dans la communication entre
le nord et le sud de l'afghanistan est
quand même un individu qui continuent à
prendre le pouvoir
à kaboul après le départ des soviétiques
bon il va faire tirer à l'armée l'autre
kaboul parce que ça résiste un peu bon
donc le personnage était pas le
personnage extraordinaire que bhl
présenter m'enfin c'est pas grave ça
montre simplement comment on médiatise
une crise les termes de la médiatisation
sont extrêmement importantes encore une
fois pour le placer dans un outillage
intellectuels ont dit oui cela c'est les
gentils sur l'est et le méchant donc
79 c'est une espèce de basculement pour
beaucoup de raisons et et à partir de ce
moment là quand commence le reflux
l'union soviétique et ben l'arabie
saoudite enrichi par la crise du pétrole
en 73 va commencer à distribuer en
quantité tous les moyens financiers qui
vont permettre la propagation du
salafisme les principaux ennemis ou les
principaux dénonciateur de cette
influence religieuse de l'arabie
saoudite c'est également le j'ai rien
parce que le gouvernement algérien quand
il s'est retrouvé
quand il s'est retrouvé dans la décennie
90 avec la poussée du fils avec la peau
c'est ensuite du gia
ils sont les premiers à dénoncer
l'ingérence de l'arabie saoudite dans le
financement des mosquées dans la
formation des imams et c'est donc tout
ça pour dire que c'est à l'intérieur du
monde arabe que la dénonciation de la
diplomatie religieuse avec ses a fait
des effets déstabilisants a été le plus
le plus dénonciateur le plus chiffres
que vous fait pour prendre conscience et
étudie
le poids du lobby saoudien en france on
nous dit tous nos dit les associations
l'audit leur compte on met tout le monde
sur écoute on fait suivre tout le monde
qu'est ce qu'on fait alors d'abord le
lobby
le lobby saoudien bon il a quelques
magnifiques résultats à son actif quand
même hein on s'oublie pas que l'on
septembre il ya 17 15 saoudiens sur 19
terroristes et que en janvier 2002 comme
bush fait le discours sur l'état de
l'union
il est dit l'exacte du mal c'est l'iran
l'irak et la corée du nord tu vois
étaient des nord-coréens quand ils ont
appris qu'ils étaient dans l'axé du mal
quoi c'est à dire qu'ils évitent
totalement la question de l'arabie
saoudite si vous dites quoi détient 8%
du pib américain parce qu'il
sait plus d'abord c'est c'est plus
pervers parce que si tu veux le lien
structurel entre l'arabie saoudite et
les etats unis c'est le moment où
effectivement ouzou welt rentrer des
négociations dit halte à et il s'arrête
sur le
arabie saoudite iran contre le roi
d'arabie saoudite et ils font le pacte
du quincy c'est à dire le nom du bateau
dans lesquelles se construit une
relation stratégique qui s'appelle
sécurité contre pétrole donc les
saoudiens garantissent que il faut
environ du pétrole en toutes
circonstances aux états unis et en
échange les américains s'engagent à
garantir la stabilité du de la monarchie
donc c'est une relation qui s'est
construite dans le temps dans lequel
effectivement il ya énormément d change
beaucoup la mairie qui ont gagné
beaucoup d'argent plus quand les
amériques les saoudiens devient de
richissimes alors là c'est encore mieux
pour donner une idée en france l'arabie
saoudite c'est le meilleur client de
l'industrie d'armement au moyen de
lycées sur les 20 ou 30 dernières années
et on n'est pas les américains c'est à
dire que simplement une puissance de
second rang comme la france peut
considérer que l'arabie saoudite ce sont
des intérêts économiques et stratégiques
significatif donc si tu veux c'est une
relation qui s'est construite dans le
temps et effectivement au moment où va
se passer la crise qui encore une fois
comment dire c'est cette relation s'est
construite dans le temps parce qu'encore
une fois on considère que l'arabie
saoudite est un allié contre le
nassérisme contre le socialisme arabe
contre l'urss et c'est donc on oubliez
toutes les petites caractéristiques qui
sont les décapitations la lapidation des
femmes et des petites choses comme ça
qui sont des détails qui n'ont aucune
importance mois donc le
nom mais c'est l'ex trader c'est à dire
si tu regarde aujourd'hui par exemple le
le nombre de manières de condamnations à
mort à la surface de la planète s'est
enfoncé on dit toujours que c'est la
chine qui arrive en tête simplement la
chine 6 1 milliards cad d'habitants si
tu veux ce qui n'est pas le cas de
l'arabie saoudite qui doit être aux
alentours de 30 millions d'habitants
mais si on rapporte le nombre de
décapitations par rapport à la
population l'arabie saoudite arrive
largement en tête c'est à dire si tu
leur apporte à lécher un échantillon qui
n'est pas la simple cumul statistiques
on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement à
l'arabie saoudite décapite beaucoup plus
que la chine mais tu vois bien que dans
les débats publics personne dit il faut
arrêter les décapitation en arabie
saoudite on va dire à la limite presque
c'est une distraction tu vois quand il
ya eu par exemple cette occupation de la
grande mosquée
donc ils ont arrêté je crois dizaine de
types ou une douzaine de types qu'ils
ont fait décapiter sur la place publique
retransmise à la télévision en direct
dans plusieurs villes du pays donc
c'était un spectacle
c'est un spectacle moi je ne sais pas
comment la chose est vécue par les
saoudiens mais ça participe d'une espèce
de banalisation de la décapitation et
serment tu connais beaucoup de saoudiens
ou de saoudiennes j'en connais quelques
heures et parle pas énormément non j'en
connais de près où j'ai connu ben si tu
veux surtout des gens qui travaillent en
arabie saoudite c'est à dire des gens
qui effectivement soit des libanais qui
travailler là bas qu'ils connaissent
bien en profondes dans la société
saoudienne et puis il y avait les
officiels saoudiens c'est à dire moi
quand j'ai travaillé à l'exportation
d'armements ont rencontré effectivement
un certain nombre d'officiels saoudien
jamais eu une discussion à bâtons rompus
autour on en emballant elle est pauvre
type moi je sais pas comment je m'en
serais sorti même si je sais comment il
s'en serait sortie de virtual donc farid
paraît-il que ce pays est tenu par
trente mille personnes
non c'est à dire qu'on s'est connecté
qui sont connectés dans tous les organes
de l'état ça va du fli qui en passant
par un fonctionnaire de base et c'est
une caste qui tient le pays d'une main
de fer
et là ils rencontrent quelques problèmes
c'est à dire que la rente pétrolière est
en train de s'amenuiser ils ont du mal à
fournir la rente
les miettes à leurs populations donc les
gens commencent à poser des questions
jamais jamais
bon je ne sais pas moi je sais que
j'avais vu comme chiffres c'est que
grosso modo les princes c'est à dire
ceux qui vont émerger à la rente il en
famille et leur famille ça fait à peu
près dix mille familles donc on
arriverait peut-être dans ce chiffre des
30000 dont tu parles mais si tu veux
c'est un cercle de deux légitimités
familiale bon lait qui sont ces alors
son transit plan
les autres sont ce qu'ils sont c'est à
dire tu vas aussi des mots des saoudiens
pauvres bon donc c'est très difficile de
si tu veux
[Musique]
j'ai essayé de montrer ce que
l'intensification de la société
saoudienne donc dans cette catégorie des
princes
il ya eu affaire qu'à chauny la fère
khashoggi est intéressante puisque c'est
une famille riche mais dans un défi si
tu veux c'est de couper de la hiérarchie
religieuse de la hiérarchie monarchique
saoudienne et qui donc parti aux états
unis qui est devenu journaliste au
washington times washington post pardon
et qui écrivait des articles
particulièrement informées puisqu'il
connaissait de l'intérieur
7,7 le fonctionnement donc la corruption
etc les machins ce qui est intéressant
c'est que khashoggi ça fait un scandale
mais ça fait un scandale parce que les
turcs l'ont révélée parce que les turcs
avaient totalement sonorisé le consul à
istanbul que le pauvre khashoggi qui est
entré là tout seul en six ans je viens
chercher mon certificat de mariage ils
pensaient pas qu'ils allaient tomber
dans le traquenard qui avait été
largement préparé puisque l'équipe des
comment dire débouchés saoudien était
arrivé avant ils étaient venus ils
étaient installés dans le consulat etc
mais comme le consulat été sonorisés
picavez les caméras vidéo si tu veux les
turcs ont vite fait de prouver que le
type était rentré mais jamais ressorti
et donc progressivement ces faits est
apparu ce scandale dont il y écouter en
direct ils ont ils sont pas intervenus
non ils pouvaient pas à cet incident
diplomatique
mais tout ce qui pouvait dire c'est le
type n'est jamais ressortie donc quand
les saoudiens ont dit non et si si
regardez le vans dans lesquelles
seraient alors voir les autres on n'a
pas vu ressortir à chauny alors qu'est
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire khashoggi participe de la bbc
que la bbc a appelé les princes félons
et prince filon ça veut dire les mecs
qui appartiennent à ce fameux cercle des
dix mille familles qui touchait l'argent
et qui souvent se sont mis une fois à
l'étranger a critiqué la dynastie
saoudienne alors tu as plusieurs profils
1 c'était le mec joueurs buveur et ses
appuis qui en avaient marre qui voulait
pas rentrer en arabie saoudite tu
pouvais voir le type qui effectivement
s'était découvert une vocation démocrate
celui qui pensait que le remplacement de
la dynastie pour nos profs à bref il ya
des profils très différents mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est que cachot vie
n'est que le cinquième de la catégorie
des princes disparu alors tu te dis
m'attend et les autres que s'ils sont
passés pourquoi est ce qu'on n'en parle
pas on n'en parle pas parce que
vis-à-vis de l'arabie saoudite qu'yves
comment veux tu faire une une de journal
avec un prince saoudien qui vit en
europe à monaco et qui disparaît toi ça
peut pas être un thème médiatique le 4k
cheville était intéressant parce que ce
n'était pas journaliste américain me
grands médias américains et dont les
preuves de la disparition était évident
ce qui n'était pas si ou coupe ah oui
alors c'est bon il ya une scène
d'équarrissage sur lequel ont
malheureusement on n'a pas de l'élément
mais enfin on suppose parce que c'est ce
qui a été je crois qu'on lui en a ramené
sa tête quand même à d'après ce que
disent les turcs ils ont ramené la tête
à
mbs par mohamed bin salman alors
pourquoi j'insiste là dessus parce que
tu te dis mais pourquoi les quatre
autres on en a pas parlé ça te dis mes
attentes y sont les experts de l'arabie
saoudite quand tu es au cinquième mec
qui disparaît c'est qu'il ya des
règlements de compte internes à la
dynastie ou au système de pouvoir et que
finalement on observe à l'égard de sa un
espèce de mutisme
les universitaires et se disent je vais
arriver y revenir c'est en fonction du
lobby mme les universitaires et jim webb
à qui ça va intéresser les diplomates
système c'est quand même leur vocation
et donc alors pour donner une idée de ce
qu'était ses proches disparus que ce
camp mais il faut comprendre comment ça
fonctionne et donc le tibet est à
l'étranger et ils critiquent choses
insupportables pour la dynastie en place
mais le type demande à l'ambassade de
lui réserver un avion et l'avion qui va
décoller de roms ont lieu en fin ou qui
va décoller je ne sais pas où de
gibraltar où les arrêts beauty à rome il
va aboutir à ryadh donc y en a deux qui
ont disparu comme ça c'est à dire avec
des avions loués une ambassade il
n'arrivait pas à destination ça te donne
une idée de l'habitude comment ces mecs
connaissent la vie internationale c'est
à dire
après tout l'ambassade aussi à leur
disposition donc l'ambassadeur de france
pas exactement le plan de vol attendu ça
te donne une idée si tu veux du mode de
vie de ces deux c'est presque disparu
donc le tout ça ce sont des choses qui
sont connus parce qu'ils suivent
l'arabie saoudite mais pour que ça
devienne un instrument ou un critère
d'analysé de la société saoudienne y
avait beaucoup d'autres arguments pour
ne pas en tenir compte ne pas en faire
une affaire d'état pourquoi les états
unis n'ont pas mis plus la pression sur
mohammed ben salman al dain thalmann
pourquoi pourquoi les mêmes la france
pourquoi on n'a pas été un peu plus
invasif alors je vais faire un petit
retour en arrière justement sur la
constitution du lobby parce que
effectivement le premier succès du lobby
saudia c'est d'abord le 11 septembre
khashoggi c'est un second succès
11 septembre donc c'est le traumatisme
absolue les vins qu'ils savent bien qui
a 15 saoudiens sur 19 il ya une
entreprise de relations publiques qui
s'appelle cauris qui va voir l'ambassade
d'arabie saoudite le 12 septembre en
attendant écoutez vos affaires vont mal
il faudrait quand même que vous prendrez
munier contre les éventuels comment dire
effets négatifs de votre comportement
et donc ils disent on va s'occuper
surtout de suivre le rapport que va
faire le congrès sur le 11 septembre
puisque c'est dans le système américain
le congrès va investiguer pour expliquer
pourquoi cette catastrophe quand même
trois mille morts avec une enquête sous
financée si son parti qu'un budget de
combien six cent mille dollars c'est ça
tu parles de kiel de la commission
d'enquêté alors pour ça les moyens
c'était illimité la question c'est le
départ au départ leurs moyens étaient
très limitées non je prolonge crois pas
enfin en tout cas je n'ai pas entendu
parler ça mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que le donc cauris va faire de
l'activisme à l'intérieur du congrès
pour essayer de faire comprendre qu'il
fallait faire attention que ce n'était
pas à l'ambassade qui avait financé
terre or tous les preuves existent et
que l'ambassade avait soutenu ou avait
loué des chambres pour le fameux
commando qui allait détourner les avions
si c'est prouvé ouais c'est prouvé et
donc cauris va se changer le portage
c'est-à-dire va agir auprès de la maison
blanche et on va vous de voir le premier
résultat de l'efficacité du lobby
saoudien c'est que quand le rapport du
congrès va sortir il ya 28 pages qui
était essentiellement dédié à l'action
de l'ambassade et à l'arabie saoudite
dans l'organisation de l'attentât et
george bush va classifiés secret défense
et 28 pages
dont classe et d'efficacité quand même
faut saluer l'efficacité du truc
le c'est obama qui en fin de mandat va
déclassifier ces 28 pages donc tu vois
il va se passer 14 avec un cas presque
15 ans toutes ces pages ont été
déclassés oui oui donc les pages si tu
veux aller avait une sensibilité dans
l'immédiat après 11-septembre là c'était
effectivement une bombe les ressortir
dix huit ans plus tard ça donne un
satisfecit à la démocratie américaine
voyant peut pas nous cacher des trucs et
cetera les effets géopolitique on était
tout à fait négligeable donc pourquoi
j'insiste sur cette société cauris parce
que donc cette socialiste corine va
évidemment obtenir des contrats très
juteux dont j'ai oublié les chiffres
mais enfin pour moi c'est des chiffres
qui sont difficilement imaginable et qui
va continuer à être si vous doutiez tu
veux c'est un on a eu des entretiens
pour écrire le bouquin avec des
spécialistes des caisses des boîtes de
relations publiques ils nous disent bon
cette boîte est connu pour être qu'on va
dire le la société de relations
publiques de tous les régimes pourris de
la planète c'est à dire qu'ils sont il
refuse aucun dossier etc
ici c'est du business bah oui wef et les
requins ils ont les endroits à là bas je
n'ai pas dit qu'il n'avait pas le droit
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le cursus
de la boîte parce que cette boîte en
2012 elle va être rachetée par publicis
donc si tu veux ce qui est intéressant
c'est le fait que
je reviens une minute j'assiste une mine
sur la structure du lobby saoudien
à partir donc du 11 septembre les roms
saoudien se rendre compte que si tu veux
ils sont dans un espèce de désarroi il
ya un max sur la boîte de comm il faut
du bim et cie céliane ah ben je panique
était illégale et ils vont je pas dit
que c'est illégal je dis simplement
effectivement ils font de la
communication pour les régimes les plus
pourris de la planète et donc ils ont
cette ligne 1 pour vous je me les
procurer précautions oratoires
parce que pour les états unis le régime
ce week-end n'est pas pourri
oui je suis d'accord c'est pas un
jugement de valeur que je porte sur
cette boîte c'est de montrer que cette
boîte a eu l'idée géniale le 12
septembre d'aller voir l'ambassade leur
dire attention alors dans le paysage il
faut se penser que les saoudiens vont se
rendre compte que nice a pas faire ils
vont se rencontre d'autant mieux que si
tu veux il ya le petit comment dire le
petit trublion qui est le qatar le qatar
a depuis les à la fin des années 80
dispose d'un budget extraordinaire quand
on découvre la grande nappe de gaz si tu
veux sur laquelle qui partagerait avec
l'iran et donc et la nappe de gaz sur
lesquels tout à coup le qatar devient
société milliardaire et qui va très vite
commencé sa société de sa politique de
communication internationale dont on
voit les effets chez nous le rachat du
psg la création de al jazeera et c'est
donc tout à coup le monstre que l'arabie
saoudite se rend compte qu'il ya un
espèce de lutins à côté qui est capable
d'avoir des résultats beaucoup plus
extraordinaires en termes de
communication parce qu'ils vont faire
avec l'aide de sociétés de communication
mais ils vont faire quelque chose qui
est très qui est très efficace le
problème c'est que c'est eux c'est la
politique du carnet de chèques c'est à
dire ils vont il suffisait d'aller à
l'ambassade du qatar et de dire oh
j'aime beaucoup le qatar d'ailleurs
jamais gêné de faire un voyage scolaire
avec mes élèves et donc on sortait
toujours à quincieux et donc quand il ya
les bouquins de chesnot et malbrunot
qui se sont contentés de tracer l'argent
c'est de dire écoutez la politique du
canada que c'est bien mais enfin il ya
un certain nombre de mecs qui émarge
quand même sur le rbe est donc tout à
coup ça a été un choc terrible et d'un
seul coup le qatar a fermé la banque
alors effectivement il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui ont migré c'est à
dire qu'ils étaient des anciens
disciples du qatar qui sont devenus des
disciples d'arabie saoudite puisque la
banque a été fermé
notamment des élus qui peuvent
éventuellement être candidat soit aux
élections de paris soit aux élections
présidentielles et donc le les saoudiens
se disent bon effectivement quand on le
fait la diplomatie du carnet de chèques
on se fait piéger donc il faut faire
autrement nous l'idée de contracter avec
des sociétés de relations publiques
ces sociétés de relations publiques m
c'est elle qui vont penser la politique
de communication de l'arabie saoudite
plusieurs caractéristiques d'abord
c'est une politique de communication qui
a pas c'est un lobby qui n'a pas
vocation à faire adopter un texte us est
du genre on va interdire je sais pas
quoi les pesticides dans
l'agroalimentaire c'est pas un lobby à
vocation d'interdiction de textes c'est
pas un lobby pour pousser d'un texte
c'est un lobby qui est fait pour qu'on
ne parle pas de l'arabie saoudite sauf
pour en dire du bien donc c'est toute
logique complètement différente de tout
ce qu'on peut avoir alors comme les
saoudiens n'ont pas de problème de
porte-monnaie ils vont contracter avec
les cinq majeur de l'histoire de la
planète c'est à dire les trois
américaines wpp omnicom et je me sois
plus d'un troisième plus publicis et
havas donc les deux françaises notamment
publicis sont les deux boîtes de
communication qui évidemment remporte
que d'énormes marchés de communication
publicis étant de très loin le plus gros
opérateur de la communication de
l'arabie saudite
alors donc comment ça va se monter seul
hobby c'est à dire comment fait-on pour
qu'on ne parle pas d'un pays passe quand
même intéressant comme techniques de
communication et ben en fait la
technique est relativement simple et
extrêmement intelligente la première
c'est que d'abord l'opinion publique les
saoudiens s'en foutent à ce point leur
sujet ce qu'on pense que pense le
français moyen de l'arabie saoudite ça
n'a aucune importance
donc il ya trois cibles la première des
cibles c'est les hommes politiques un
homme politique qui va en arabie
saoudite un leader un executive il faut
qu'ils reviennent satisfait bon c'est
très simple on lui signé une lettre
d'intention par une lettre d'intention
tu sais ce que c'est c'est nous nous
engageons à discuter pour 10 milliards
de contrats ça veut pas dire que c'est
aussi 10 milliards ça veut dire le type
revient valls revient à paris et y
regarder avec moi 10 milliards de
promesses de contrats ça marche c'est
une des hits pardon tu connais la des
hits c'est à dire c'est un rendez-vous
tu crois que tu veux conclure mais tu
cook lupin à je connais pas là
l'expression mais pareil avec trump 30
d'arabie saoudite lui ses 110 milliards
valls étaient 110 milliards il n'y a pas
eu de contrat après mais c'est important
c'est que l'homme politique revient dans
son pays et dire regardez j'ai bien
travaillé j'ai bien travaillé puis c'est
un client donc on peut pas mépriser
deuxième cible c'est les hommes
d'affaires belges hommes d'affaires la
grande idée de mohamed bin salman c'est
la cité les hommes la cité du futur où
les livraisons se ferait avec des drones
où il y aurait tout ou serez câble et
enfin bon donc c'est la cité high tech
qui va d'un seul coup
faire le basculement de la d'économie
pétrolières à une économie de la haute
technologie bon
on te promet 500 milliards de dollars tu
es invité hoda roche du désert tu te dis
500 milliards de dollars ça suscite le
respect donc même si je gratte 0 5% je
fus richement donc les hommes d'affaires
ont toujours de davos très satisfait du
davos du désert toujours très satisfait
pas ce qui est un peu le point qui de
poil à gratter si tu veux sur lequel il
faut se pencher c'est que moi m bensalah
n'est pas le premier leader saoudien à
promettre la cité du futur fadi la donne
a promis 2 ou 3 les autres en ont promis
chacun avec toujours l'idée qu' on va
transformer l'économie essentiellement
pétrolières à une économie de la haute
technologie ça pose quelques petits
problèmes sociologiques c'est à dire
mettre au boulot des saoudiens qui sont
habitués à la rente à la gratuité de
l'eau à la gratuité de l'électricité
c'est pas évidente voire kirill
d'esclaves comme respectueux alors oui
effectivement il ya les ja les immigrés
mais enfin bon c'est pas cela auquel le
discours disputée d'essayer alors
ensuite deuxième chose tu veux faire une
cité de la haute technologie en en
faisant venir des pme tu vois de pointe
tu vas aller convaincre une pme
française leader dans son marché d'aller
s'installer dans un pays où le code du
commerce et la charia
donc qu' aucun début de ces projets n'a
jamais été réalisé mais évidemment tueur
et amorce la pompe à chaque fois on dire
matin et celui là c'est le vrai c'est
celui qui va marcher 500 milliards $
encore une chambre donc les hommes
d'affaires où jouera d'agos non s'y
connaît le savoir-faire de
l'organisateur de davos et y prendre
toujours satisfaits ils ont droit à un
entretien avec un conseiller du prince
et cédera donc eux ils se taisent
troisième cible sociologique c'est les
leaders de la communauté musulmane à
l'étranger
les leaders de la communauté musulmane
étrangers le postulat est simple vous
critiquez l'arabie saoudite vous
critiquer l'islam
c'est gênant alors comme le produit
phare de l'arabie saoudite pour les
musulmans c'est le pèlerinage
et quand tu vois qu au cfcm tu as un
certain nombre de mecs qui possède des
agences de voyages et dont le produit
pilote c'est quand même le personnage et
le cfcm c'est quoi la rue pendant le
conseil français du culte musulman tu as
quelques individus si tu veux qu'ils ont
comme activité principale des agences de
voyages est évidemment dans ces agences
de voyages le produit phare c'est le
pèlerinage à la mecque donc si tout à
coup l'arabie saoudite leur diaouné mais
cette année il y aura moins de visas
parce qu'il ya le coc vie parce qu'ici
parce qu'il a ça et c'est
bon donc ils ont fait intégré l'idée que
effectivement un pour des leaders de la
communauté musulmane critique et
l'arabie saoudite s'étaient critiquer
l'islam bon donc une fois que tu a réuni
ses trois fleurs d'opinion
tu es tranquille encore une fois
l'opinion publique tu t'en fous donc le
savoir faire de ces bois de relations
publiques c'est d'avoir décline tout ça
alors il faut quand même quelques
propagandistes quand même tu peux pas
rester sur un simple silence donc
comment est ce que ce montrent le
système plaît si tu veux je te raconte l
épisode de cauris et donc de cette boîte
qui a été rachetée par
publicis
le système est une espèce d'arborescence
c'est à dire t'as effectivement le
commanditaire supérieur qui est l'arabie
saoudite mais entre le contrat qui est
passé entre l'arabie saoudite et un de
55 grands acteurs se 56 5 riders des
sous traitants si la porte des sous
traitants cela prend des sous traitants
et donc quand tout à coup on reçoit une
invitation pour le visité l'arabie
saoudite parlementaires sénateurs ou
autres bombes ont officiellement
l'individu n'est pas invitée par
l'arabie saoudite il est invité par une
boîte de quoi mais tu sais si tu as et
ensuite
ça donne les bonnes consciences si tu
veux pour dire on est invité on visite
on découvre
après c'est la nature des questions que
tu veux bien poser c'est à dire est ce
que tu veux demander qu'est-ce qui est
devenu doujaïl à la clown tu cette fille
qui s'était permis de conduire à leur
qualité pas autorisé à le faire qui a
été autorisée a été immédiatement
interne et qui vient et qui a été
condamné à trois ans de prison et qui
vient d'être libéré sous la pression
internationale bon tu te poses pas
question là dessus ça fait désordre tu
vois même quand il ya des sommets du g7
ou du g20 on va pas déjà dérangée l'an
protocolaire donc du moment qu'on arrive
à sauver la face bon il ya même eu une
sénatrice qui a osé déclarer que le le
programme de déradicalisation saudia
était efficace il faudrait s'en inspirer
simplement quand tu transformes un
salafiste wahhabite le chemin est plus
court que pour faire d'un démocrate de
salafistes voit donc effectivement tu te
dis il ya quand même des remarques qui
tu veux de qui pourrait être
effectivement un peu un peu tempéré donc
ces propagandistes là peuvent servir si
tu veux temps en temps pour dire moi je
suis allé en arabie saoudite j'ai fait
si je fais ça voilà donc le système est
un système qui marche bien on estime que
grosso modo l'arabie saoudite doit
dépenser à peu près 2 à 3 milliards par
an c'est uniquement pour la france où
mondial pendant que sur la france une
des goudes c'est uniquement pour les
entreprises dont on connaît les contrats
ce qui ne veut pas dire que ce soit la
totalité de la somme mais donc on voit
bien que alors il ya aussi un thème de
communication qui est extrêmement
intéressant pour l'arabie saoudite c'est
que
à chaque fois que tu sais l'ordre
protocolaire lors de successions est ce
qu'on appelle un ordre adelphique
l'ordre adelphique c'est que abdelaziz
saoud le père fondateur avait eu douze
femmes alors tu sais que pour respecter
les règles de l'islam il en avait que
quatre à la fois quand même c'est un
homme qui était très croyant donc il a
envie de divorcer d'une quand ils en
prenaient une nouvelle donc avec ses
douze femmes il a eu je ne sais combien
d'enfants mais où 52 je crois d donc
l'ordre de succession c'était le premier
fils le premier mâle de la première
femme auquel succéder le 1er floral de
la deuxième femme auxquels succédaient
le premier mâle de la troisième femme et
ainsi de suite bon ce qui est expliqué
que tous les deals lé roi d'arabie
saoudite sont tous des nonagénaires
aujourd'hui puisqu'ils s'étaient tous du
même père si tu veux avec quelques
années différence ce qui s'est passé
avec salman l'actuel roi c'est que celui
là il devait arriver probablement en
bout de chaîne ou en tout cas celui qui
lui succéder était peut-être plus vieux
que lui j'en sais rien toujours est il
que il décide de nommer son petit fils
mohammed bin salman ben donc moi m 25
mal la belle gueule le mec il peut faire
la couverture de n'importe quel homme un
magazine sur papier glacé tout à coup on
dit à celui là c'est l'homme du
changement simplement quand tu regardes
qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya eu un roi qui
a succédé un autre c'était toujours
l'homme du changement c'est à dire
comment savait pas quoi dire sur ce qui
se passe est dedans japon dire non mais
cela on le connaît selon du changement
donc il n'ya pas de pays plus immobile
que celui là mais qui était toujours
qualifié en cours de changement pour
yahia jamais eu aucun changement le
premier qui a commencé à autoriser les
femmes à conduire c'est à la suite de la
faire à la toule c'est à dire en fait il
ya quatre cinq ans bon donc tu vois ce
système de communication consistant à
dire m'attendais celui là vous allez
voir il va changer c'est faux mais il ya
jamais ce retour en arrière c'est comme
les grandes cités d'high tech qui vont
se construire d'arabie saoudite si tu
fais un temps minimum de retour en
arrière ça qu'elle n'a jamais eu aucune
qui a vu le jour il ya même des
immeubles vides si tu vas riad parce que
les images sont occupées par personne de
france de se positionner par rapport à
ça est ce qu il ya encore une france où
est-ce qu'on est
dirigée par une petite caste qui est
cupide et en mal de pouvoir qui se
laisse subordonnés
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
on doit se positionner dire mon bas dans
ça suffit quitte à subir les
conséquences commerciales et économiques
que cela implique
qu'est ce qu'on fait on reste là pays le
pays des droits de l'homme et ont fait
cocorico comme une coque en route son
tas de fumier à 6 heures du matin où on
continue de baisser la tête et picorer
des graines par terre bon d'abord
d'abord le le
l'acteur principal sur le plan
géopolitique ces états unis c'est à dire
qu'on peut adopter n'importe quelle
position
ça n'aura qu'un effet très partiel c'est
évidemment sur l'évolution du système
saoudien le seul pays qui a suspendu les
ventes d'armes notamment à cause du
yémen c'est l'allemagne tous les autres
suite le sud nous will actuellement ce
mais c'est à propos de la sphère du
yémen ce n'est pas à propos de le faire
quand je veux dire il ya évidemment le
mélange des deux mais en tout cas merkel
est la seule à avoir décidé d'
effectivement d'arrêter les ventes
d'armes à l'arabie saoudite mais sinon
tous les autres ça a été comment trouver
un faux fuyants pour dire oui mais
attendez tout à fait est si grave il
faut quand kate arrive à son terme etc
il ya une enquête qui a été fait par
l'onu par une française qui s'appelle
agnès callamard qui a conclu à la
responsabilité complète de la hiérarchie
en particulier de l'entourage de mohamed
bin salman
pour dire que effectivement il ya aucun
doute là dessus la france pourrait être
poursuivi que pour crimes contre
l'humanité avait que ces ventes d'armes
à l'arabie saoudite
mutsch alors sur le glas de la sur le
cas de l'arabie saoudite oui mais enfin
encore une fois les ventes d'armes en
elle même ne posait pas de problème
politique moi je sais j'en ai fait
pourquoi parce qu'en fait l'arabie
saoudite quand elle achète des armes et
dieu sait qu'elle y mettez de l'argent
elle n'achète pas des armes pour faire
la guerre mais lâcheté des hommes pour
des garanties de sécurité l'arabie
saoudite n'a jamais fait la guerre à
israël or il ya la frontière dans le
golfe d'aqaba et à une trentaine de
kilomètres entre les lattes et la
frontière saoudienne ya une trentaine de
kilomètres une fois ils ont envoyé une
brigade au cours de la guerre des six
jours en 67 mais le temps que la brigade
arrive en jordanie et la guerre était
finie donc il n'y a pas de contentieux
militaire avec la avec israël mais par
contre c'est un pays qui effectivement
il doit avoir un budget de défense
supérieure à la france par exemple donc
tu te dis pourquoi toutes ces armes si
ce n'est justement parce que ça achètent
des garanties de sécurité ça achète une
relation stratégique et effectivement
quand tu es dans un pays démocratique tu
te dis bon temps que ces armes ne
servent pas il n'y a pas de quoi se se
préoccuper
une petite remarque toutefois on n'a
jamais vendu d'avions de combat dans la
vie saoudi donc ce n'est pas la peine
d'accuser d'assaut de la politique
saoudienne
dassault n'est certainement pas le
pilote c'est vrai c'est pas l'industrie
d'armement qui est pilote dans cette
surface ouvre une parenthèse avec ce qui
se passe les marchés de vente d'armes la
france a vendu des armes à l'inde et il
ya un gros scandale de corruption qui
est en train de sortir en ce moment
c'est pas parce que tu es un avis dessus
quand on entend que
ça s'est un peu arrosée par tous pour
pouvoir emporter les marchés s'étaient
l'ancien temps c'était ça se fait
toujours un csdhi - qui se passe non
les affaires de corruption sur les
marchés d'armement sont aussi vieux que
marchés d'armement bon pourquoi parce
que c'est une vente dans lequel se sont
un état qui vont à un autre état ou en
tout cas qui fait un accord bilatéral
qui est couvert par le secret défense
bon donc à partir de ce moment là la de
l'état acheteurs si tu va accepter de
payer une surfacturation dont évidemment
les modalités de distribution vont se
faire par des intermédiaires et être
versé sur des comptes en suisse ou sur
des comptes et serbe ont simplement un
il s'est passé un phénomène qui a posé
beaucoup de problèmes c'était une vente
de lockheed martin américaine à l'italie
et là il y avait des grosses commissions
sur les hommes politiques italiens qui
ont été révélés par la d1 par les
journaux italiens et donc c'est un fait
un scandale qui remontait aux états unis
et donc à partir de ce moment là les
américains ont été les principaux
pilotes pour faire une convention
internationale contre les commissions
dans les marchés extérieurs il était
d'autant plus intéressé que considérer
que si les autres continuent à verser
des commissions ce serait une distorsion
de concurrence donc la seule solution
pour eux c'était de dire non il faut une
norme internationale
donc j'ai pas dit que c'était mieux
donner encore une fois mon jugement de
valeur moi si vous voulez mon témoignage
il faut pas le préjugé si tu veux
toucher un salaire de 20 août on a vu
des pots de vin dans l'état français
quand tu disais ah bah oui enfin moi je
n'ai pas participé malheureusement je
suis désolé mais enfin je sais qu'il n'a
eu quoi qu'est ce qui s'est fait
graisser la patte bardon qui esquisse
effet graisser la patte pour moi il y en
avait à peu près sûr tous les contrôles
sur l'âne si tu veux les ventes de
mirage 2000 des scandales et c'est donc
il n'y a pas de jeu peut pas de donner
des noms je peux dire que c'était une
pratique qui jusqu'à 1997 c'est à dire
au moment où dans le cadre de l' ocde
ont signé une convention contre les ce
qu'on appelle les frais commerciaux
exceptionnels dans des affaires
d'armement donc à ce moment là la norme
a été fixé par les américains et les
américains se charge de faire respecter
la chose ce moment donc ça a été un gros
traumatisme parce que tout à coup il
fallait changer complètement les
modalités il fallait faire attention etc
etc et comme tu sais que la justice
américaine s'est donné un pouvoir ex
territoriales ça voulait dire que le
véritable gendarme de l'implication de
l' ocde c'était la justice américaine
est évidemment ça a de quoi faire
trembler pour n'importe quelle société
qui a des intérêts aux états unis donc
il ya eu une espèce de grand traumatisme
si tu veux qui s'est fait en dix ans
mais attention attention toute
l'économie générale des contrats
d'armement vont changer ça va pas
changer tout de suite ça je te rassure
pourquoi parce que dans un pays comme
l'arabie saoudite l'idée même de
corruption n'existe pas puisqu'il ya pas
de distinction que le budget de l'état
et le budget de la famille donc si tu
verses aux décideurs que lui décide d'en
faire une partie pour sa famille ses
proches pour alimenter le système tu
dans le système ocde il faut que ce qui
est ce qu'on appelle une double
incrimination c'est à dire qu'il faut
que le vendeur reconnaissent qu'il ya de
la corruption mais que l'acheteur à
reconnaître et de la corruption or si tu
vends dans des pays du golfe qui aura
jamais un pays qui reconnaîtra que de la
corruption donc tu vois faire un espèce
de formalisme juridique mais qui ne
correspondent pas redon pour alors pour
lundi meilleur gagne a régulièrement des
scandales de corruption parce que c'est
une démocratie dont il ya des
journalistes qui vont investiguer quand
il ya un changement de pouvoir pour
régler à des règlements de compte
politiques et c'est donc dans des pays
comme l'inde c'est pas un pays plus
corrompus que l'autre les taux de les
taux de marge si tu veux dans l'ain
arabie saoudite ça doit être de l'ordre
de 20 à 30% d'un montant d'un contrat
mais on est dans des dans des
fourchettes qui sont relativement
similaires si tu veux est ce que c'est
pour ça que le pakistan
est un peu dur avec les ressortissants
français les intérêts français ce que
c'est pour ça que les français le quai
d'orsay a conseillé à ses ressortissants
de quitter le pakistan
sous des prétextes religieux de la
sphère sympathie ainsi de suite est ce
qu'il ya une pression sur l'état
français parce que l'état français est
de mèche avec l'état indien sur les
contrats d'armement alors là franchement
je double au râtelier c'est-à-dire armes
les indiens et armé pakistanais alors le
cas du pakistan est un cas un peu
particulier parce que je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais donc un moment
un ressort la sphère de ce qu'on appelle
les sous marins pakistanais on est en
pleine campagne électorale balladur et
premier ministre il pense qu'il a ses
chances pour devenir président mais
manque de chance chirac tient le parti
donc balladur n'a pas d'argent affaire
karachi l' affaire karachi alors la
sphère karachi contexte français c'est
léotard ministre de la défense balladur
candidat premier vise donc ils se disent
le seul moyen d'aborder les cas c'est
effectivement de ceux alimentés sur le
mécanisme des contrats d'armement et ses
contrats d'armement normalement c'est
des commissions converse aux acheteurs
mais là on monte un système de
rétrocommissions c'est à dire qu'on va
voir faire revenir une partie de
l'argent pour alimenter les caisses du
candidat balladur bon il ya deux
contrats qui sont qui ont été construits
comme ça il ya le contrat sous-marin
pakistanais mais il ya aussi le
sous-marin frégates saoudiennes bon donc
le ce contrat sous-marin pakistanais
qu'est-ce qui va déclencher la mécanique
c'est que d'un seul coup il ya un
attentat contre des ingénieurs de la
direction des constructions navales qui
sont là-bas pour le contrat sous-marin
pakistanais
donc le juge qui en l'occurrence
trévidic pensent que c'est uniquement
parce qu'on a cessé de verser les
commissions puisqu'on avait bloqué les
rétrocommissions en france et donc que
c'est la vengeance
bon moi j'étais au ministère de la
défense à l'époque dans le jury voir
trévidic j'ai dit non pour une raison
assez simple c'est que on a arrêté
uniquement les commissions destinées à
des mecs identifiés et donc si tu veux
là on a on a fait du chantage c'est à
dire on m'a dit tiens si l'on va arrêter
de payer et c'est donc il ya des mecs
qui sont venus se manifester au
ministère de la défense en disant
comment se fait-il qu'on ne touche pas
au contrat et il aura fallu leur envoyer
là le service action de la dgse pour
l'odeur calmez vous bon donc on savait
ce qu'on avait arrêté
et donc c'était pas du tout ça ne
remettait pas en question du tout le
contrat de la dcn donc c'était bien un
attentat islamiste est pas un attentat
de vengeance correction bon le lendemain
je me retrouve sur les gens dans le
monde en disant le chaînon manquant de
l' affaire karachi enfin peu peur donc
ça c'est des souvenirs personnels mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il y
avait eu le même processus sur les
frégates saoudiennes mais tu remarqueras
qu'on n'a jamais ouvert dans la quête
sur les frégates saoudiennes parce que
l'arabie l'arabie saoudite l'a fait
comprendre dans un bar est là parce que
nous d'abord c'est pas de la corruption
chez nous puis ensuite si c'est comme ça
on arrête des contrats donc si que les
moyens de pression de l'arabie saoudite
montrent qu'on pouvait traiter
différemment le pakistan et l'arabie
saoudite donc pour le pakistan après ça
devient une histoire beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que tu as effectivement
au pakistan une espèce de comment dire
d'émulsion chimiques de production de
salafistes est devenu radicaux de toute
nature qu'on va régulièrement retrouvé
un peu partout et c'est donc si tu veux
le côté menace il se dit on se
positionne par rapport au péquiste a dit
wow je crois que si tu veux quand il ya
eu à faire de l'afghanistan
donc on va envoyer ses jeunes turbulents
si tu veux aller combattre en
afghanistan mais les bases arrières sont
au pakistan
donc ce que l'arabie saoudite va faire
ça va être essentiellement de financer
des mosquées et des camps des écoles etc
dans lesquelles ils vont enseigner le
wahhabisme évidemment elles vont pas
enseigné à démocratie et donc il ya une
espèce de vérole qui s'est installé à la
frontière entre le pakistan elle est là
l'afghanistan en plus c'est ce qu'on
appelle les territoires du nord-ouest
c'est à dire des territoires qui sont
théoriquement autogéré donc on a là si
tu veux une alchimie qui a été alimentée
par dans les zones tribales oui c'est ça
la zone tribale et donc il ya là quelque
chose sur lequel le régime pakistanais
lui même n'avait pas de véritable
maîtrise dans lequel il ya eu cet argent
qui a abondé avec ses trafics d'armes
avec l'afghanistan enfin bref on a tous
les éléments si tu veux d'un d'une
déstabilisation dont le rendement de
karachi avait aucune envie de s'occuper
quoi il préférait que ça reste tourné
vers l'afghanistan
donc l'arabie saoudite a alimenté cette
alchimie et donc qu'il existe au
pakistan des choses sur lesquelles même
le gouvernement de karachi n'a aucune
maîtrise c'est pas impossible il faut
aussi le voir comme ça donc la relation
dont l'arabie saoudite est le truc je
sais pas le financement saoudien n'est
pas qu'un financement public c'est à
dire on peut pas dire l'ami saoudite a
versé tant d'argent tu as des tas de
familles qui ont de l'argent et qui sous
des couverts humanitaire sous l'idée de
créer un hôpital pour les jeunes
pakistanais tout ce que tu veux verse de
l'argent et encore une fois ils vont pas
vérifier quelle est la qualité de celui
qui encaisse l'argent donc c'est une
l'arabie saoudite a servi de 10 machines
distributrices si tu veux d'argent mais
avec toujours une même ligne et
intellectuelles et qui était évidemment
pas de faire avancer la démocratie
je continue ma parenthèse qu'est-ce
qu'on fait les qu'erdogan qu'est-ce
qu'on fait que la turquie qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pardon avec pearl oil erdogan
et la turquie est ce qu'on doit
continuer à essayer de se rapprocher
d'eux ou de les faire se rapprocher nous
est ce que la turquie à d'autres agendas
est ce que l'europe a les capacités de
discussions sur un pied d'égalité avec
avec eux quand on a vu le scandale
de comment un joli son volet de la
commission robe louis de la commission
européenne c'était fait exprès pas fait
exprès c'était pour faire galles pour
galvaniser ses troupes au sein de son
pays histoire de montrer que c'était lui
le patron et qui est femme il fallait
les relégués sur le canapé ou dans la
cuisine c'était quoi
si tu veux sur la turquie il faut garder
plusieurs choses en tête la turquie est
un pays qui vit sur deux modèles
différents il ya le modèle atatürk mona
turc c'est la modernisation nature qui
passe par l'occidentalisation de la
turquie
ce modèle il a été un peu ses limites
puisque finalement la candidature de la
turquie a toujours été repoussés avec
des moyens plus ou moins des arguments
plus ou moins ténus si tu veux pour ne
pas la faire entrer en europe
et le deuxième modèle c'est
effectivement il faut quand même penser
que la turquie la turquie d'europe c'est
pas plus grand qu'un département
français et que l'essentiel de la
turquie est un pays anatolien bon et ce
pays est anatolien c'est une pratique de
l'islam très traditionnels etc et donc
ardoines et leurs représentants de cette
tendance si tu veux qu'ils considèrent
que l'identité musulmane de la turquie
doit prendre le pas sur cette identité
comment dire laïque avec avait poussé
atatürk ample troupes turques
pour la capacité à mentir oui maintenant
je sais pas si le plus menteur au moins
menteur que traitement fait il est pas
loin dans la catégorie bon et donc le
plusieurs remarques sur la turquie donc
la turquie a beaucoup exporter ces
travailleurs essentiellement vers
l'allemagne un peu moins sur la france
mais ce qui différencie les migrants
turcs des migrants maghrébins c'est que
pour les migrants maghrébins on est à la
troisième génération alors que les
migrants turcs on est dans la première
ou deuxième génération pourquoi ça fait
une différence c'est que si tu veux r
douanes en particulier considère que le
ministère des affaires culturelles
turques doit contribuer à contrôler les
migrants les turcs travaillent en europe
même s'ils sont de nationalité française
par l'intermédiaire du financement des
mosquées par l'intermédiaire de la
désignation des imams et c c'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont dans la même politique que
ce qui était par exemple l'algérie après
un mois de la première génération c'est
à dire on garde le contrôle de nos
émigrés
mais simplement effectivement on le voit
bien avec la sphère de milli gorus c'est
à dire que tu as donné lieu à des
associations qui ne veulent absolument
pas ce qu'ils craignent le plus c'est
l'idée que ya une espèce d'islam des
lumières et qu' il ya des des musulmans
qui s'intègrent dans les sociétés
occidentales en perdant une partie de
leur identité donc si tu veux leur but
le but de cette association milite brut
avec un autre organisme chapelle le déni
tu sais de conserver de d'entretenir de
veiller sur les lieux turquie sont des
lieux de prière les lieux de commander
les mosquées financées par la turquie et
on le voit bien que ces deux
associations ont refusé de signer la
charte de l'islam de france or dans
c'était il ya une conférence de presse
pour la regarder parce que c'est les
représentants de billig au rucher du
deal it qui t'expliquent plus démocrate
que moi tu meurs j'ai pas signé la
convention mais je te jure que je suis
absolument pour la laïcité pour la
tolérance pour le terrain et les deux
raisons pour lesquelles ils ont refusé
de signer c'est l'égalité hommes-femmes
et c'est la reconnaissance de la post
asie c'est à dire qu'ils ont refusé de
signer à l'idée qu'on puisse changer de
religion et l'idée que les femmes
puissent être les qualités de l'égal de
l'homme est effectivement tu comprends
bien parce que il ya ce qu'on appelle la
convention d'istanbul la convention
d'istanbul d'une convention
internationale qui fait que les pays
signataires reconnaissent l'égalité
entre l'homme et la femme or la turquie
s'en est retiré il ya six mois donc
c'est tout à une espèce de continuum
intellectuelle qui est une régression du
régime d'ardoyne que deux qui se traduit
par les positions du dignité de la et
d'amélie gauche or on se retrouve à
strasbourg avec effectivement une
mosquée encore une fois à financer par
un avec l'aide de la turquie pour lequel
le milli gorus demande une fille
subvention à la mairie de strasbourg et
on s'étonne que la mairie de strasbourg
verse une subvention à une association
musulmane qui a refusé de signer la
charte de l'islam de france
toi alors tu te dis attendez ce que les
verts sont devenus fous mais en tout cas
bon il a fallu le scandale qui s'est
fait pour que mes livres je retire sa
demande de subvention donc c'est pas la
mairie strasbourg qui a dit non c'est
milito rouge qui sous la pression a
préféré faire profil bas et d'entretien
strasbourg s'est positionné comme ça
c'était quoi c'est l opportunisme
c'était façon de récupérer des votes
c'était c'était quoi s'attirer les
bonnes faveurs
tu sais dans l'âme dans la simple goutte
de la bêtise
qu'est ce que tu veux je te dis cela
j'ai vu encore ce matin une vidéo où il
tient un conseiller verts qui refuse de
subventionner une base navale dans je ne
sais quelle ville et
le yacht club est alors la mère lui dit
mais c'est de la navigation à voile oui
mais il ya certainement des bateaux à
moteur
il a dit aux subventions subventions pas
le yacht club parce que c'est nous nous
donnons pas de l'argent à
des choses qui polluent ouais c'est ça
donc ça fait marrer tout le monde parce
qu'ils ont fait c'est un club de voile
bah oui c'est un gap de waele donc c'est
ce que l'effet revoir qu'à la mer enfin
visiblement il était sur ce
rebondissement son réseau nous tient la
route sauf qu'il n'est pas beau c'est
son dossier
je ne sais pas peut-être que si tu veux
la concurrence allait vers avec entre
les verts c'est plus celui qui est celui
qui invente la formule la plus idiote si
tu veux a des chances de monter dans la
hiérarchie j'en sais rien ça c'est
gratuit ce bail out clause qui interdit
le tour de france à lyon tour de france
le tour de france avec les 25 bagnole
qui
oui mais dans ce cas là interdit les
matchs de foot parce que ça écrase les
vers de terre si tu veux que s'arrêtera
le ruiner gazon moi je veux dire tu peux
pousser à l'extrême situe ce genre de
raisonnement le tour de france ça fait
partie de l'axé pratiquer la course
cycliste la plus grande du monde c'est
une forme de radicalisation c'est aussi
a beaucoup aimé ses ambitions
complètement complètement donc c'est eux
tu as effectivement des gens qui veulent
faire à marche forcée la conversion vers
ce qu'il croit être s'il croit être le
la société non polluantes ouais mais tu
t'aperçois que c'est pas le seul domaine
tu vas voir les menus végétariens
c'est une progression est à des gosses
pour lesquelles il m'a jamais dit on
alors il y avait le seul endroit où
manger de la viande c'était à la cantine
pourra même se poser la question aussi à
l'envers si vous leur donne une
alternative en terme de protéines pardon
c'est quoi si vous leur donnez le
terrain et il en termes de quotas ben
oui mais c'est dieu qui va qui va
auditer les menus qui sont servis par
une municipalité dirigée par la vague
qui va estimer que tu vois ça ressemble
aux khmers quoi au clair il a ils sont
partout le sang vert mais ça ressemble à
ça c'est à dire on va vous imposer la
règle qui est la règle de l'avenir bon
écoute tu peux tu peux donner lieu
regarde celui là qui avait même pas
travailler sur dossier qui pensait qu'il
allait pouvoir faire un grand geste
politique qui se retrouve piégé parce
qu'il a une ligne idéologique
qui croient que la réalité c'est celle
que son idéologie vous avez fini tu sais
c'est une caractéristique des de la
france il ya un anglais qui avec un
bouquin très rigolo qui dit s'appeler ce
pays qui adore tant les idées et
pourquoi est ce qu'ils écrivaient ça
parce qu'il est très frappé il était
très frappé par l'idée qu'en france les
débats sont d'abord idéologique avant
d'être factuel je tends cite des
exemples
dans l'entre-deux-guerres dans
l'entre-deux-guerres juste une
parenthèse d'avions dans les cantines en
général c'est très mauvaise qualité
cc je vais pas dire que c'était de la
lasagne de cheval ne voulais pas le
choix écoute ça j'en sais rien c'est
dieu moi je suis passé à travers ça je
vais vous j'étais plus intéressé par les
frites par la viande enfin bon c'est pas
grave c'est pour dire que si tu veux
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
effectivement
on va effectivement modifié c'est donc
revenons sur les racines de ce
radicalisme dans tout le spectre
politique
en face de nous donc je
parle en général pas spécialement d'un
radicalisme religieux moment oui mais
c'est englober aussi comment vous fait
pour combattre ça comment on fait pour
des radicaliser les gens pour les
apaiser pour qui dialoguent entre eux on
essaie de renforcer le système éducatif
pour éviter qu'ils écoutent les douces
mélopées de tous les prédicateurs de
tous bords que ce soit on y lit cuit là
on a une population qui va simplement
réagir à l'instinct avec des grands
gourous les nouveaux gourous un peu
partout et on va se retrouver avec des
gens qui vont j'excuse moi l'expression
mais ils vont finir par vraiment c'est
taper sur la gueule voilà c'est vraiment
la question que pose est effectivement
intéressante beaucoup plus général si tu
veux que les radical religieux l'écart
est également religieux étant la forme
la plus évidente si tu veux delà de ce
séparatisme
bon
tu le vois dans les cantines scolaires
c'est à dire celui qui dit moi je suis
juif pratiquant une fois nous sommes à
nous cacher l'autre qui dit moi je suis
à la main musulmans dans une foire
panale donc finalement moment la
puissance publique dit mais je peux pas
fournir 10 rames et des repas à tous les
enfants selon les principes religieux
bon donc effectivement on fait un espèce
de formules menu minimum ou alors tu as
le mec et les parents d'élèves qui vient
de voir un prof en disant vous n'avez
pas grande enseigne isla vous n'êtes pas
musulman donc pas ce genre de pratique
là qui sont des pratiques qui est il si
tu veux une espèce de séparatisme je
suis en train de faire un bouquin là
aujourd'hui justement sur le séparatisme
dans le type pour être est ce si grave
bon pourquoi je l'appelle ça comme ça
parce que je me suis amusé si je puis
dire a recensé depuis la fermera toutes
les formes de séparatisme
lisible à travers la presse un j'ai pas
cherché à creuser les services de
renseignement ni quoi que ce soit c'est
à dire toutes les formes qui dans
l'opinion publique peuvent être
perceptibles pas et donc je prends comme
acte de séparatisme depuis si tu veux le
le fils qui vient à la mairie pour
appeler son fils jihad et qui se voient
refuser ce prénom jusqu'à l'attentât
terroriste c'est à dire j'essaye de
balayer large et je suis frappé par deux
choses
d'abord la progression des domaines et
des postures on va expliquer ma femme
peut pas être soigné par un médecin un
rom etc on va avoir à l'école les
parents qui disait pas devancer islam
vous n'êtes pas musulman et puis
évidemment jusqu'au sommet de l'attentât
terroriste
alors il ya quelque chose de très
troublant j'en suis à 500 ou 600 à peu
près donc depuis la fermera de
différentes postures de de séparatisme
this fiscale ou si tu as fait pardon
séparatisme fiscale tu le fais à fils
calme ne fait pas ça donc le un fait qui
est très intéressante donc il ya
plusieurs actes de violence
les attentats terroristes relativement
on arrive à peu près à les recenser mais
simplement il ya un cas de figure que je
trouve très intéressant c'est le type
qui sort dans la rue si tu veux qui va
donner un coup de sabre un passant
n'importe lequel et qui va crier allahou
akbar
et quand le policier arrête le type il
regarde sur son téléphone portable est
en général le type il a une vidéo de
décapitations et puis une programmation
d'appartenance à l'état islamique mais
parfois même pas rédigés par lui
et quand fois que le type si tu veux si
cris allahu akbhar il est garantie
d'avoir la presse la police et la
justice
aux états unis si le type va pas bien
comme c'est le cas avec ce type que je
te cite il prend sa kalachnikov qui va
dans un supermarché tire dans le tas
c'est à dire qu'il ya une espèce de
psychanalyse psychologie sepsie
canalisations si tu veux de la société
française qui fait que si tu crées
allahou akbar et garantie de sortir ton
de tourner isolement que tu as psychose
si tu veux tu as créé il ya une centaine
de cas comme ça donc tu t'aperçois que
le comment dire cette conversion est
tout à fait superficiel mais que par
contre l'appétence pour la violence que
je te dis la vidéo de décapitation des
chats fourni à peu près 900 vidéo de
décapitation pour te dire que
effectivement si tu as envie de voir du
sang tu peux trouver tout ce que tu veux
depuis les aides décapitation en groupe
la balle dans la tête l'enfant qui tue
un impôt un militaires syriens etc
ou des vidéos de guerre où les
américains bombardent aluminium à
l'uranium appauvri où il ya du phosphore
blanc balancer sur des civils ça aussi
ça radicalise tu parles de quoi tu
parles de la converture parle du de la
posture du type ici oui là bas bien sûr
oui mais si tu veux le
cette radicalisation encore une fois ça
veut dire qu'il ya dans l'air de du
temps si tu veux l'idée que
la radicalisation islamiste est la cause
si tu veux qu'ils traversent la société
française
cette radicalisation n'est pas sortie de
nulle part non plus c'est à dire que le
le terrain de jeu de nos militaires
depuis 80 ans et le moyen orient c'est à
dire qu'à chaque fois le centrafrique ou
signe pendant son train fric aussi oui
mais si tu veux c'est beaucoup plus
léger en centrafrique d'abord il ya la
mine turckheim market ça va nous coûter
combien ça va nous coûter ce sera autre
chose mais si tu veux quand tu veux
avoir débarqué cent cinquante mille
soldats un moment de l'invasion du
koweït dans un pays qui est
théoriquement interdit aux mécréants
ça fait ça peut faire désordre quoi et
donc tu vas avoir des femmes qui
conduisent des jeeps et quant à la
police religieuse qui les arrête c'est
la femme qui lui donne une raclée aux
types parce que c'est une femme
militaire etc donc si tu es il ya
beaucoup de phénomènes de
déstabilisation dans cette société qui
était une espèce de cocon qui vivait à
l'écart de tout et qui se permettait de
donner des leçons à la planète tant qu'
à partir de la guerre du golfe si tu
veux il ya une espèce d'autorisation que
se donnent les occidentaux d'intervenir
absolument partout en disant mais nous
sommes en est leur position nous sommes
une opération de maintien de la paix où
nous allons combattre contre la force du
mal qui va être saddam hussein puis
ensuite assad et c'est donc démocratie
pour les petites chardon ou n'importe la
démocratie pour les petites filles oui
oui c'est ça surtout à coups de
bombardier si tu es donc tu sais on a
fait une étude d'après la guerre en 45
alors que les campagnes de bombardements
sur les villes allemandes étaient
gigantesques de se demander pourquoi il
avait tenu jusqu'au bout
et pourquoi la population ne veut pas
lâcher le régime est en fait en posant
des questions les sociologues américains
sont rendu compte que quand et sous les
bombardements tu es plus solidaire de
celui qui te protège que de celui qui
bombarde tu me diras s'est pas plaint de
faire une étude pour contrôle vers ça
mais mais c'est pour dire combien si tu
veux on croit qu'une population va
fléchir par exemple quand il ya eu le
dernière opération sur gaza si tu veux
par les hommes et les israéliens ils ont
plus déverser de bombes au mètre carré
que l'on avait d'ailleurs c'est sur
l'allemagne nazie dans les dernières
années et tu crois que ça fait plier pas
le signe à certaines sources et des
sources de ça c'est quoi pendant mes
sources de ça je sais plus je me
trouverai quand tu veux mais si tu veux
c'est important est ce que c'est le
nombre le kilo de nombre de kilos de
bombes au mètre carré en gaza c'est plus
petit qu'un département français tu vois
donc évidemment tu livres une bombe de
500 kg sur un département français
étaient déjà vides dans les hautes dans
le haut de gamme quoi bon donc
7 cette posture là c'est à dire l'idée
qu'on peut utiliser la force parce que
nous l'avons pour résoudre une crise
c'est une espèce d'ivresse l'hubris
comme disaient les grecs qui pensent
qu'il fait qu'on a intervenu
militairement sur des tas de domaines et
aujourd'hui tab hayden qui dit bon c'est
fini on s'en va d'un coup c'est à dire
au bout de 10 ans ou 12 ans
d'intervention américaine en afghanistan
et on s'en va sans condition
ces troupes qui avaient initié
80 v dc dont ckoi trump il avait dit
quoi il n'ya pas initié ce mouvement là
il avait initié en partie pour l'irak
mais bon il ne devrait pas il n'avait
pas quitté l'irak mais là aujourd'hui on
a un président des états unis
nouvellement élu qui dit l'afghanistan
on s'en va or la seule force constitue
en face et les talibans donc tu te dis à
temps quelle était l'utilité de cette
guerre déclenchée après 2001 pour
montrer qu'on était capable de se venger
pour aboutir à un résultat aussi négatif
que celui là se venger ici avec les
talibans vivant il fait peut-être se
venger saoudi au premier non parce que
justement ben laden c'était censé s'être
réfugiés en afghanistan les saoudiens il
avait vite compris si tu veux le danger
que représentait il avait lui-même
expulsé déjà auparavant donc il était
réfugié au pakistan en afghanistan et
donc ils vont faire cette opération de
guerre en afghanistan qui va vite se
résoudre puisque évidemment la
supériorité militaire est évidente mais
simplement ça ne résout en rien le
problème en plus qu'est ce qui est
arrivé dans les fourgons de l'armée
américaine en afghanistan
les évangéliques avec des tonnes de
bible
donc tu vois mais toi dans la tête d'un
avenant
moi je suis allé en afghanistan la
différence entre talibans et en
afghanistan et un abri en normal y en a
pas c'est à dire qu'ils ont tous les
deux fusils si tu veux et tu peux pas le
dire ça fait rentrer dans leurs têtes
celui-là c'est un radical sous la selle
dès pas mais quand tu fais du
renseignement technique tu regardes les
mecs par avion là il ya un affrontement
avec des mecs qui ont des fusils
par exemple c'était la guerre en irak
est particulièrement intéressante la
technique militaire américaine est assez
simple on à la supériorité donc au casse
tout et à la fin l'adversaire demande la
paix donc tu casses les infrastructures
les centrales électriques comme agen et
ses arbres et quand les américains
débarquent en irak c'est vrai qu'ils ont
débarrassé le pays de saddam hussein
mais les âmes oubliées irakien qui
n'avait plus ni l'eau ni l'électricité
ni la sécurité ni machin ils disaient
non à la dictature c'était mieux ça
marche et quand même c'est vrai ce que
veut dire c'est à dire la contradiction
entre l' usage des moyens militaires et
l'objectif politique et parfois évidente
mais on est tellement convaincu que
l'envoi de militaires est une solution
alors que ce n'est comme moyen tu sais
quand robespierre disait personne n'aime
les missionnaires armés
il avait déjà tiré la conclusion en 1793
donc c'est pour te dire que ça ne change
pas le système militaro intellectuelle
dont je parle quand je t'ai parlé tout à
l'heure c'est tous ces gens qui vont
convaincre d'envoyer des militaires et
là sur le champ je te lis je te lis deux
questions internet
la chine vient d'annoncer qu'elle va
construire un immense barrage à la
source du fleuve brahmapoutre
qui alimente ensuite l'inde
après les tensions au cachemire sommes
nous à loudes d'un conflit majeur entre
ces deux grandes puissances nucléaires
et même avec le pakistan
je ne sais pas si on est à l'homme si tu
veux ce qui est certain c'est que
les
l'histoire des fleuves 7 mai est une
histoire ancienne pendant les guerres de
lounor oui oui c'est ça à la guerre de
l'eau bon il ya un moment où
effectivement où tu sais les soudanais
avait fait un barrage qui perturbé la
distribution des journaux égyptiens
l'époque au pakistan faisait
effectivement sur la source du gange à
barrages qu'ils allaient perturber la
serbe a donc cédé scénario qui sont
assez fréquents qui ont qu'on peut
d'ailleurs facilement résoudre pour des
ports des négociations est ce que pour
autant ça va amener la guerre j'avoue
que je n'en sais strictement rien
simplement je fais un art et image si tu
veux sur l'inde et le pakistan
l'inde grâce à gandhi est peu apparu
comme le pays de la non-violence
bon simplement il a fait 20 fois plus de
guerre que la chine depuis 49 ils ont
fait trois gars avec le pakistan ils ont
fait une invasion du sri lanka ils ont
fait la répression du temple d'or quand
il ya eu le nationalisme sic donc je
veux dire comme pays de la non-violence
7e le bilan la comparaison entre la
communication c'est ce que je sais sur
quoi j'insiste tout le temps c'est à
dire les images par rapport à la réalité
est en bas il faut regarder la chose la
chine a fait une fois la guerre contre
l'inde et puis il ya eu la région
militaire du tibet en 50 tragiquement
mais tu te dis mais là pour pourquoi il
y en a un qui est lue comme une menace
et l'autre qui est pas lu comme une
menace tu vois ce que je veux dire bon
on pense qu'on veut des routes de la
soie on pense qu'on veut de la politique
chinoise en afrique enfin quand on pense
à la politique française en afrique si
tu veux on n'a pas en dépendant droit de
critiquer ce que font les chinois en
afrique tu vois et ça ou dialysés
d'usaid les ouigours ou pas du tout ils
ont proposé l'asile ont proposé quelque
chose nos rangs les saoudiennes offre
pas l'asile a même pas fait même pas
aussi rien aux irakiens c'est à dire que
si tu veux je crois qu'ils l'ont
accueilli à peu près un million de
réfugiés syriens ou irakiens c'est à
dire beaucoup maintenant on a fait
l'europe libre pour que le libre bon
donc on est face à un pays si tu veux
qu'ils aient le sommet d'hypocrisie
puisque la défense des musulmans etc
enfin attendez vous n'êtes pas saoudien
banques et caen sort la frontière donc
tu te dis mais quand ces mecs vont nous
expliquer que la france est islamophobe
je veux dire moi je vous expliquerai
comment ces choses se passent pourquoi
l'arabie saoudite qui a de l'argent et
de l'espace n'accueille pas les réfugiés
syriens et irakiens toi tu peux le dire
dans une dans un débat public interpelle
l'ambassadeur d'arabie saoudite ils vont
te dire mais non c'est pas vrai nous
payons des hôpitaux etc mais tu vois
bien qu'on est dans quelque chose qui
est une espèce de négation entre la
réalité et l'image donc après ça c'est
plutôt amusant analyser tout ça parce
que tu te dis la vie internationale est
une espèce d'hypocrisie la turquie
accueille il est
jugé pour des questions religieuses pour
des questions de
darb avec les migrants c'est à dire
qu'ils ont militarisé les migrants les
stockant à la frontière de l'europe et
aux impressions sur l'europe non je
crois pas je crois que si tu veux
d'abord le les conséquences de la guerre
d'irak et puis là du conflit en syrie
d'abord ont été provoqués par nous
rappelez vous rappelle quand même que
tout ça est une espèce de destruction
de l'irak et destruction qui était une
espèce de bombes à retardement d'autant
plus évidente que tous ces pays du moyen
orient sont des pays qui ont cette
caractéristique que tu connais sur
toutes les cartes c'est à dire qu'ils
ont des frontières rectiligne si c'est
des frontières rectiligne ça veut dire
que ces frontières ont été tracés sur un
tapis rouge qui était évidemment le
tapis rouge de la des négociations de la
première guerre mondiale donc ces pays
n'ont pas d'unité les programmes
d'unification sociologique si tu veux
c'est est ce que faisait le socialisme
arabe met enfin en disant quand même que
le dictateur ils préféraient s'appuyer
sur sa composante à lui que sur la
totalité des trains donc le rasad et un
d'halévy donc c'est un minoritaire
chiite alors que le pays est à majorité
sunnite que en arabie saoudite
il ya 13% de chiites mais ces chiites
ils n'ont pas les mêmes droits que les
sionistes enfin donc si tu veux tous ces
pays sont des pays qui sont extrêmement
hétéroclites tu le vois bien en irak où
effectivement les kurdes auquel on avait
promis un état en 10 118 bons sont une
composante importante de la population
etc etc et une majorité chiite alors
qu'en fait ça n'amuse assad mais saddam
hussein n'était pas un sunnite donc tu
t'aperçois que à partir du moment où tu
mettais un élément explosif dans cet
ensemble l'habitude faisait éclater ce
qui était soi disant un pays donc après
ça il ya eu ce phénomène de guerre
civile c'est à dire que finalement les
américains qu'ils s'attendaient est
accueilli les bras ouverts en irak se
sont trouvés face à une insurrection qui
était d'autant plus évidente que la
première chose qu'a fait le proconsul
américain
qui a été nommé par les américains à
commencer par débaucher toute la police
toute l'administration tout la justice
etc et donc les irakiens qui n'avait
plus encore une fois ni l'eau ni
l'électricité n'avait plus la sécurité
des plages du cices si tu veux ils ont
ils se sont ralliés massivement à des
gens et en particulier ils ont licencié
l'armée c'est à dire cette armée qui
savait se battre puisqu'elles avaient
fait la guerre contre l'iran était
devenu si tu veux un bébé c'est devenu
immédiatement un noyau de résistance
contre la présence américaine et il a
méricain comprenais pas pourquoi il se
heurter à cette résistance puisqu'il
était venu en libérateurs il faut
rejouer le scénario de 45 en france
mais encore une fois parce que c'est
plus facile
d'analyser la complexité d'une crise
avant d'envoyer des militaires que de
décider rapidement d'envoyer des
militaires et donc éventuellement en
inventant c'est ça c'est une des
caractéristiques des républicains
américains c'est qu'ils sont capables de
mentir publiquement de la même façon que
george bush désigne les trois pays
l'iran l'irak et la corée du nord alors
qu' à l'arabie saoudite de la même façon
on va dire tu connais l'histoire de
l'irak on va expliquer qu' il ya des
armes de destruction massive alors que
l'aï eu à l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie explique que le programme
nucléaire est complètement démantelée
par contre il était difficile de prouver
qu'il n'y avait pas de programme
chimiques ou bactériologiques parce que
ça ça se fait dans les hôpitaux
donc quand on accuse saddam hussein
d'avoir repris le comment dire levrat
nucléaire c'est faux parce que le
programme nucléaire c'est un programme
d'infrastructures lourdes faut faire des
centrales hors sas et de la surveillance
technique paraître par satellite qui te
permet tout de suite de détecter dit
qu'ils avaient des centrifugeuses dont
des kabyles où il y avait quoi ces
centrifugeuses dont les camions oui mais
c'était pour fabriquer du chimique ou
bactériologique et donc là effectivement
on pouvait prétendre que mais en même
temps si tu veux il y avait eu des
vagues d'inspecteurs qui disaient tous
non il n'y a plus rien donc tu peux
sortir une image d'un gros camion
désormais attention vous savez ce camion
si on vous dit pas toute la vérité mais
c'est un camion qui fabrique des machins
aidera donc avec la force si tu veux de
conviction du système de renseignement
américain
ça ça bouscule ça déstabilise
question internet de grégoire y at il à
vos yeux parmi ceux qui commencent à
émerger un candidat pour 2022 qui vous
semblent à même d'appliquer les mesures
qui
vous
préconisez pour lutter contre le sel est
le salafisme en france
si tu veux on est dans un système
aujourd'hui dont aucun candidat ne peut
se défaire complètement
je vais prendre un exemple qui est
l'intégration juridique européenne
actuellement si on veut expulser un type
il ya cinq instances de 500
juridictionnelle qui peuvent être saisis
du dossier bon il ya évidemment la
juridiction française l'appelle la
cassation et ses hommes ayant plus la
cour de strasbourg et la cour de
luxembourg ça veut dire qu'on a
construit un système juridique
protecteur des droits qui est pas
système autobloquant autobloquant au
sens où effectivement tu ne peut plus
aujourd'hui expulser un mec alors
pourquoi j'insiste là dessus parce que
justement il ya eu deux débats si tu
veux qu'ils ont été saccagés par ce
système de construction européenne bon
le premier c'est celui là c'est à dire
que finalement on nous la france est en
cours d'année l'un refusant enfin un ps
voyant interdire de deux d'expulser un
type seul on le retrouve sur le ventre
jusqu'à sa mort il ya eu 70 type qui
aujourd'hui sont assignés à résidence et
keith qui vivent sur la république
française des fois dans des villages et
les mecs demande à être approchés de
leurs femmes de leurs enfants etc c'est
à dire ils demandent à retrouver une vie
normale qu'il ne devrait pas avoir si on
avait appliqué les mesures d'expulsion
mais ces types on ne sait pas quel est
leur degré de dangerosité
dans le droit français on considère que
quand tu as fait ta propre à peine de
prison tu t'es amendé combien de mecs on
a retrouvé si tu veux qu'ils n'étaient
pas dans le mandé du tout bon donc on a
un système situent eux qui aujourd'hui
qui s'est perverti avec le temple qui
était le système du droit d'asile le
droit d'asile et à une convention
internationale qu'on a signés dans les
années 50 parce que tous les pays
démocratiques se sont reprochés d'avoir
refusé les juifs que hitler avait
déclaré apatrides tu sais que hitler
donc décide que tous les juifs allemands
n'ont plus un sou est tellement donc ils
se retrouvent apatride et toutes les
démocraties les refuges bon ça va être
la shoah et ça va être un massacre et
c'est donc après guerre on décide de
faire une convention sur le droit
d'asile pour qu' on puisse accueillir
des gens qui sont évidemment des
défenseurs des libertés qui sont menacés
dans leur vie par un régime oppressif
mois
la première vague c'est évidemment les
réfugiés d'europe de l'est donc
effectivement sont des défenseurs des
libertés mais ça le système va se
pervertir parce qu'à ce moment-là à
partir des années 80 a commencé à
cueillir des types qui sont des réfugiés
parce qu'ils sont menacés de la peine de
mort chez eux quoi qu'ils aient fait et
donc va se constituer le landau distant
dans lesquels on va recevoir comment
dire accueillir des islamistes radicaux
qui tiennent des discours moi je les
écoutais hyde park corner il fallait
entendre ce qu'ils racontaient les types
et il y avait le bobby si tu veux à
l'anglais ce qui se baladait les mains
dans le dos non c'est la démocratie
américain devant quand tout à coup il ya
eu les attentats de londres les anglais
ont vite retourné leur veste à ils ont
expulsé tout le monde visiblement ça
veut dire que ça n'est pas injouable
comme ça donc le sais tu veux on a un
système qui autobloquant qui est
celui-là deuxième débat surréaliste à la
française ça a été la déchéance de la
nationalité le débat ouvert par hollande
s'était il faut pouvoir déchoir de
nationalité des gens qui sont des
binationaux puisque c'est la condition
juridique importante
parce que ces types là n'ont rien à
faire sur le territoire français ils ont
déjà été condamnés c'est
la déchéance de nationalité existe déjà
dans le code civil article 25 c'est la
déchéance pour fait de trafic de drogue
et il ya également le 27 qui je crois
qui est pour les gens qui ont pris les
armes contre l'armée française
tu te dis attend on pourrait pas prendre
la déchéance de nationalité pour faits
de terrorisme sur le territoire français
on est à 2 190 morts et 900 blessés dans
les rues de paris on pourrait pas
expulser et on pourrait pas déchoir de
sa nationalité un un terroriste donc tu
te dis mais attend le système
démocratique français il fonctionne sans
aucune connexion avec la réalité des
faits là je suis dans le bouquin dont je
te parle sur le
est ce si grave j'ai retrouvé le cas
d'un
français condamnés à 25 ou 30 ans de
prison en irak par la justice irakienne
pour voir pris les armes avec edf etc et
qui appelle qui a réussi entre en
contact avec sa propre famille et qui le
dit je suis malade on ne soigne pas je
vais mourir et c'est la famille mobilise
les ong
le prisonnier a droit à des soins le les
ong amnesty l'aise et laisser les
achètent c'est à la ligue internationale
des droits de l'homme va se faire
pression sur le quai d'orsay pour que le
type soient rapatriés en france
le type est effectivement rapatrié en
france il est soigné en france
finalement il se rétablit et puis une
fois qui s'est rétabli on le retrouve
six mois plus tard en tunisie en train
de faire du trafic d'armes bon il ya que
amnesty qui se soit excusé tous les
autres dire mais non mais nous nous
c'est notre rôle c'est à l'état français
de survie mais tu te rends compte ce
degré d'irresponsabilité
c'est à dire viser des organisations
humanitaires françaises qui 10 mai ah
ouais non mais nous on a fait on a fait
notre rôle enfin si tu ne peux pas quand
tu as le cas d'un si tu veux d'un type
dont tu ne connais pas le dossier tout à
mouiller pas tu dis pas à temps un seul
type il a vraiment un dossier médical ce
qu'il n'est pas condamné pour avoir
égorgé les enfants des choses comme ça
tu vois tu te mobilises pas sur des
principes mais quand c'est le cas comme
ça non mais attendez c'est une très
belle cause voilà donc tu as des cas
comme ça qui font que la société
française sur sap à ce sujet me
désespère un peu autant la légitimité si
tu veux d'action de défense des droits
de l'homme nommé de défense des
journalistes etc sont des actions si tu
es bon tu peux comprendre si le dossier
est constitué
mais en même temps quand tu dis on vit
on on va faire prévaloir le principe sur
la réalité ça devient grave quoi
candidat laurent gbagbo le candidat ça
je m'en fous complètement
écoute je sais pas je sais pas si ben
c'est dur pour encore une fois parce que
l'évolution de la société française est
fait de telle manière que même si tu es
dit un candidat tu t'aperçois que de
toute façon après tu as un mécanisme de
blocage qui fait que quoi pardon qui
vient de coûts et de la haute
administration
non non non dit non parce que tu en fais
partie tout à fait partie non si tu veux
moi j'ai un cas c'est que j'ai vécu
personnellement qui était la crise au
rwanda
la grille du rwanda parce que justement
on est en plein dedans aujourd'hui
moi j'étais à l'époque à la délégation
aux affaires stratégiques et donc en
juin ou juillet 93 donc six mois avant
le génocide je fais un papier sur le
rwanda j'avais un bureau afrique si tu
veux dans ma direction et donc j'entends
parler du rwanda je sais que ce pays
bref je travaille un peu le dossier avec
mes collaborateurs et puis je fais un
papier qui est un pelé qui s'appelait
plaidoyer pour un réexamen de la
politique française au rwanda dans
lequel j'y disais je comprends pas
l'intérêt stratégique qu'on me raconte
sur ce pays qui en plein centre de
l'afrique à côté du zaïre en face à man
ça n'a strictement aucun intérêt
stratégique c'est pas une offensive des
anglophones contrairement à ce que je
râle chambly sur certains papiers parce
que encore une fois c'est pas parce que
si tu veux pour de donner une idée la
construction d'un argumentaire
stratégique inca gamme est le patron
d'une des tutsis était un mec qui avait
passé toute son enfance dans les camps
de réfugiés en ouganda bon on vous
n'avez pas lui demander d'aller au lycée
français de kampala pour apprendre le
français donc le mec était anglophone
alors c'est pour ça pour le quai dossier
c'était la preuve que les anglais
étaient derrière mais là on le mec parle
anglais donc et avaient des arguments de
7,2 ce degré de bêtise 12h05 body chic
ben pas seulement le quai d'orsay tu
avais alors tu avais aussi si tu veux
des militaires qui étaient en
coopération avec l'armée rwandaise bon
alors si jamais qui il formait des sous
officiers français des officiers
rwandais et puis à chaque fois que les
officiels ont démonté au contact du
front contre le fpr des fois il se
faisait gonfler donc qu'est ce que
faisait les officiers en formation ils
essaient de comprendre pourquoi lors
leurs élèves s'étaient fait gonfler et
donc ils montaient de plus en plus près
du tu vois du du front pour essayer de
comprendre mais en même temps
appartement où tu franchis la ligne
rouge tu te rends pas compte tu vois ce
que je veux dire bon et simultanément tu
vas avoir ces mecs qui vont ainsi devoir
expliquer leur échec mais évidemment en
dix ans mais il nous faut plus de moyens
donc tu vois comment se construit un
cercle vicieux bon bref mon papier part
je me fais engueuler par le cabinet
militaire qui me dit mais quand on
connaît pas un sujet on n'en parle pas
et ses six mois plus tard c'est le début
du génocide dans lequel l'ambassadeur
hockey à kigali raconte que c'est des
rumeurs
bon
quand on se rend compte de la gravité de
la chose
on décide de monter l'opération
turquoise l'opération turquoise étaient
donc une opération d'interposition entre
hutus et aussi pour arrêter le massacre
c'est difficile de monter une opération
comme ça quand a été maquée pendant des
mois et des mois avec le régime
emplacement le président habyarimana
était mort dans son accident d'avion
enfin dans l'attentât contre son avion
est donc encore une fois c'était une
situation d'urgence dans lequel il
fallait des uns la sur cet attentat je
sais pas moi j'ai pas d'information je
veux pas me prononcer là dessus ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qui se passe après
rare c'est rare que tu dises non une
heure il ya des tas de choses que je
sais pas le mystère de la création je
connais pas non plus sur moi donc le ce
qui est intéressant plus tôt c'est le
reste c'est à dire comment se construit
la la décision donc finalement
tous ces mecs qui avait défendu la
politique française au rwanda se sentant
un peu vers 2 si tu veux quand
mitterrand décide l'opération turquoise
il faut donc trouver les la solution
pour que des troupes françaises viennent
sans interposition dans un lieu de
conflit pas évident comme un bon donc on
se
le quai d'orsay dit nous on va envoyer
quelqu'un voir kagamé au br pour lui
faire comprendre que l'armée française
devient pas combattre etc qui est ce que
choisit le quai d'orsay ils choisissent
l'ancien ambassadeur de france à kigali
celui qui avait dit que c'était des
rumeurs comme nous on était au ministère
de la défense de l'aca c'est une affaire
sérieuse s'il faut pas s'amuser à
envoyer des troupes qui vont être pris
évidemment pour des belligérants et donc
on décide d'envoyer rufin qui était au
cabinet de léotard et pruniers le seul
spécialiste du rwanda enfin loin des
grands spécialistes du rwanda il est
marié qu'une rwandais ce mois
c'est eux qui vont entrer en contact
avec kagamé pour leur dire écoutez les
troupes vont arriver comme ça ils vont
se déployer comme ça le commandement des
opérations spéciales arrivera en tête
pour venir vous au contact et on va
établir une ligne de communication entre
vous et nous pour que s'il ya une
ambiguïté on puisse se parler
directement dispositif situent eux pour
sécuriser la chose
mais kagame leur soit parce qu'ils
avaient prunier
réunion à la direction du cab directeur
de cabinet au ministère de défense où il
y avait le directeur de cabinet le chef
du cabinet militaire le directeur des
affaires stratégiques comme moi même et
puis prier le seul qui n'avait aucune
raison d'y être puisqu'il était pas chef
du mans ont fait réunion entre chefs
français c'était le seul qui connaissait
le rwanda à personne d'entre nous ne
connaissaient le rwanda évidemment nous
on était les théoriciens
et donc on était en train de monter le
dispositif de l'opération turquoise et
donc le chef du cabinet militaire dit on
va se servir d'une base aérienne qui
accable qui a qui gagnent à palm havas
sur la juste au litre à la frontière du
zaïre et du de l'ouganda dont j'ai
oublié le nom de la plateforme enfin en
dix ans les avions pourront se poser là
donc on va se déployer dans le nord ça
limitera les communications etc c'est
donc l'idée du dispositif turquoise
c'était dans la région nord de luanda
c'est de la technique militaire on
n'avait pas grand chose à dire le chalet
encore une fois qu'ils connaissaient le
rwanda s'étaient brouillés et pruniers
il dit mais écoutez moi je connais rien
à la technique militaire tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que si vous mettez
dans le nord il ya plus de tout ce
qu'ils ont tous été massacrés ils sont
réfugiés dans les collines du sud donc
si vous arrivez que vous mettez vous aux
militaires dans le nord personne ne
croira que vous venez défendre des
tutsis donc on va vous prendre une fois
de plus pour des vols internationaux
militaires pour défendre vos anciens
alliés dans la minute de silence qui
s'est passé dans le cabinet quand bruni
a dit ça mais tu avais l'impression que
d'un seul coup il y avait le tête qu'il
plaque le ciel qui tombait sur la tête
de tous ces gens qui étaient les chefs
mais qui encore une fois ne connaissait
pas le sujet s'il est vrai pas été là
bas il y aurait eu des massacres et de
massac le soldat français et c'est donc
pourquoi j'insiste sur cet épisode parce
que cet épisode là te montre la façon
dont se construisent la réflexion de nos
élites nos élites sais
je suis à paris un capital d une grande
puissance occidentale j'ai fait des très
bonnes études j'ai été labellisé chef
etc etc et donc je vois le monde comme
la vie politique française veut le voir
partir sur d'autres régions là où on
voit l'otan la russie faire un concours
de la plus grosse à la frontière pour
parler tout à fait trivialement
exercices de l'otan exercice de la
russie
bâtiments américains en mer noire
avion américain qui vient de lécher la
coûte aux russes les russes bon le
prennent mal le russe
qui s'est saisi de la crimée le russe
qui en train de sponsoriser le donbass
ça c'est en masse que brydon a besoin de
nouvelle guerre froide point sur ses
positions est ce que qu'est ce qui se
passe parce qu'on va aller au carton et
côte on va pas on va pas aller au carton
d'abord parce que si tu es personne n'a
envie de faire la guerre ça coûte trop
cher ça coûte cher tu veux dire que
mobiliser les français pour les défendre
de doune baba survenir
c'est ça rappelle narvik là on va couper
la route du fer
donc non je reviens à une d'un peu sur
cette crise parce que air encore une
fois si tu comprends paraît solide
ukraine pardon pour aller sauver
l'ukraine contre l'ours au bus ouais
mais si tu veux si tu ne comprends pas
quel est le bag horn qui constitue
l'identité des belligérants c'est à dire
des russes des ukrainiens des
occidentaux etc si tu prends le cas de
l'as bompas exemple de l'ukraine
l'ukraine donc c'était la mère patrie de
la russie elle rappelle toi c'est le
la russie se fonde à kiev puis ensuite
elles migrent et elle va vous passez à
moscou et c'était bon mais quand
l'ukraine si tu veux et de l'ukraine est
un pays dont la frontière n'a cessé de
transe l'été parce que après 10 917
quand y'a le prêt de brest-litovsk si tu
veux l'ukraine de la transplanter vers
le vers l'est bref et puis ensuite quand
il va voir la victoire de 45 puis ils
vont transiter vers l'ouest mais enfin
entre temps il se passe un phénomène qui
est évidemment un élément important de
l'identité chrétienne c'est que dans les
grandes mesures de staline si tu veux
quand il ya ces grandes famines situés
en europe via l'ukraine est
particulièrement touchée puisque c'est
le pays producteurs de céréales auquel
on va piller on va voler toutes les
productions et il va y avoir en ukraine
quelque chose qui s'appelle l'holodomor
c'est à dire en fait une espèce de
comment dire de massacre par la famine
chez les ukrainiens qui restait
évidemment comme quelque chose de très
profond et quand les allemands vont
arriver en ukraine en 41 eh ben tout à
coup ils vont être pris pour des
libérateurs et donc l'ukraine va
constituer une brigade qui va les battre
avec les allemands contre les russes bon
tu vois que déjà comme le scénario
devient simple quand il ya évidemment là
le retour que les uns des forces l'armée
rouge arrive au reconquiert l'ukraine
etc puis après il va y avoir tout ce
phénomène de vengeance d'extermination
et ses
portes dans l'histoire soviétique la
crimée donc a été normalement russe mais
quand khrouchtchev devient premier
secrétaire du parti communiste il va
donner la crimée à l'ukraine parce que
lui-même et ukrainiens il va considérer
comme geste d'amitié que la crimée
soient rattachés alors je sais plus
précisément c'était dans les années
55-60 choses comme ça bon
donc tu te dis encore une fois dans un
pays dont les frontières n'ont cessé de
france l'as tu es à droite et à gauche
et dans un pays dans lesquels on rajoute
un morceau
quelle est la légitimité de dire oui ça
c'est à moi ça c'est pas moi
qu'est ce que fait poutine il va donc
nous faire le coup des comores vous
allez comores tu sais quand on a voté
l'indépendance des comores il ya un chat
lille qui a refusé l'indépendance et
mayotte à l'audi a6 et mayotte veut
rester français va rester français les
comoriens ne cesse de réclamer le
rattachement de mayotte à la france 8
m'enfin grandes déclarations de grandir
de la droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes donc mayotte devient
française mayotte aujourd'hui c'est la
plus grande maternité de france parce
que évidemment tous les comoriens vient
de faire accoucher leurs femmes
enceintes amour à mayotte de façon à ce
que les enfants puissent avoir la
nationalité française plus tard chez les
effets indirects si tu veux de cette
mansuétude de la république fasse a dit
et quand tu dis mais nous on a fait le
coup à mayotte pourquoi les russes ils
nous feraient pas le coup en crimée dans
lequel il ya 70 à 90 pour 80% des temps
qui sont russes
il fait un référendum qui va voter leur
attachement à la russie et lui on lui
dira non non non ça c'est pas bien vous
n'avez pas le droit tu vois ce que je
veux dire c'est pour ça que la vie
internationale mérite la connaissance
historique parce que si tu veux quand
c'est un hymne thorel d'hypocrites comme
c'est le cas là on se dit mais attention
au suivi un nom chez lui il a pas le
droit je dis mais pourquoi pas le droit
que j'ai fait la même chose
l'autre caractéristique aussi pareil
quand il ya donc les grandes
manifestations à kiev qui vont
progressivement faire la coupure si tu
veux avec moscou une des premières
mesures de l'ukraine indépendante c'est
de dire l'ukrainien est la seule langue
officielle en ukraine dans lequel il ya
encore 10 h et + 20 % de russophones qui
sont essentiellement dans la partie est
à cause de ces phénomènes de translation
de mecs qui sont retrouvés à l'époque
dans un pays qui s'appelait l'union
soviétique qui se demandaient pas s'il
serait plus tard ukrainien aux russes et
donc si tu veux au lieu d'arrêter ce
processus
de durcissement
ont dit
attendez des russes il faut pas
commencer à les maltraiter et donc
effectivement d'après la voie est royale
pour les rues de diam attendait cela
sont des russophones pourquoi ils
n'auraient pas droit eux aussi à leur
étable on a déjà eu des cas comme ça ou
vendu des coupes de l'éclatement de
l'urss il a eu la moldavie il ya eu des
cas comme ça où à chaque fois il y avait
des petits morceaux de territoire faut
penser que dans la psychologie ruche
quand l'urss s'écroule il ya 17 et à
nouveau qui naissent plus un certain
nombre d'états autoproclamé tu te rends
compte du traumatisme que ça représente
dans un pays qui a été la grande
puissance du xxème siècle une des
grandes puissances du 20e siècle et qui
tout à coup se retrouve dans un état
dont les frontières ont reculé de 400 km
avec des pays dans la magie de centrales
qui sont des pays qui d'un seul coup se
sont déclarés indépendants qui vont
retrouver leur identité musulmane et
c'est donc le choc si tu veux dans les
70 je pense dans l'opinion publique
russe c'est de se dire vivement le
premier vingt rappelle-toi que qu'à
l'époque de eltsine l'ivrogne qui était
au
au kremlin 40% de l'économie russe et
est démonétisé c'est à dire que la crise
économique qu'ont connu les russes à la
décomposition du rss ça voulait dire que
tu échanges et des chaussettes contre
des pommes de terre tu vois bon quand
tout à coup arriver un mec qui va
reprendre en main tout ça qui va faire
payer les oligarques qui avait payé qui
avaient pillé le pays à l'époque de
yalcin quand quand il décide de
poursuivre khodorkovski pour deux
complices était le mec donc un ces
oligarques qui était milliardaire à 25
ans il a réussi mieux que moi ce pour
une raison assez simple c'est qu'il
avait racheté une compagnie pétrolière
russe au dixième de son prix à l'époque
yalcin
donc quand tout-à-coup août il décide de
lui faire cracher l'argent
on dit bien est ce qu il fait une oeuvre
de salubrité publique où est ce qu'on va
l'emmerder les ans mais vous n'avez pas
le droit parce que le dossier le respect
des droits de l'homme etc on devrait
saluer quelque chose qui est un espèce
de rétablissement d'une de quelque chose
qui est une espèce de l'égalité qu'elles
soient républicains nous permettre une
forme de l'égalité dans un pays qui a
été dont les richesses ont été
totalement pillé mais non non non
attendez à voir n'est pas content que la
justice en russie ça va pas et c'est
donc tu vois cette espèce de décalage
entre cette position morale dans
laquelle on se met et la position réelle
c'est-à-dire la connaissance du dossier
khodorkovski moi je ne le signerai pas
une pétition pour sauver la tête toi
mais en même temps c'est tellement beau
de pouvoir dire non mais la russie vont
dépendre c'est vraiment poutine regarder
ce qu'il fait et c mais si on ne
comprend pas la position intellectuelle
et le background culturel de l'autre
c'est facile d'en faire un ennemi
quand on voit
tic et tac se balader salisbury avec du
vin dans la petite attaque du devis de
choc dans les poches
on peut se poser des questions aussi
compris ce que tu dis là une tentative
d'assassinât avec ludovic choc ah oui
oui oui on peut se dire aussi quand même
ah oui
non mais attends moi je ne veux pas en
conclure que poutine est un enjeu et
d'un âge la question c'est encore une
fois moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est le
procès de fabrication de l'ennemi tu
peux avoir effectivement ce n'est pas le
mec qu'on va assassiner à l'ombre et tu
vas avoir khashoggi dci ouais c'est ça
vous prenez salvan et puis tu vas avoir
khashoggi qui est découpé en morceaux
bon tu te dis même scandale à la limite
les deux sébastien d'hérin qu'il l'a
fait avec du produit chimique et l'autre
qui l'a découpé avec un boucher que tu
te dis c'est il y en a un qui est pire
que lot mais tu vois bien que la posture
est différente des sanctions au niveau
des sanctions au niveau de la
dénonciation etc on va effectivement
tram dit l'avait dit il a dit c'est pas
un bs
il ya un hospice quand spécialistes
appellent alexandre adler qui est un
spécialiste de tous c'est à dire que lui
il a une caractéristique avant d'y
écrire ses articles ses qui cite les
services de renseignement donc si tu
veux il te dit dans cette région du
monde où les services pakistanais sont
très actifs n'a pas un mec dans la salle
qui va se lever l'album dire excusez moi
je suis le porte parole des services
secrets en scène pakistanais vous
raconter n'importe quoi l'avantagent de
citer les renseignements c'est que tu es
sûr de n'être jamais contredit donc lui
il est créé un article extraordinaire au
monde à faire qu'un show dit pour
expliquer qu'en fait en fait ces airs
doan qui responsable que tout ça ça a
été manipulé et c'est bon on manque de
bol pour lui le lendemain mohammed bin
salman reconnaît que c'est l arabie
saoudite mais si tu veux je te dis mais
à part le type devraient disparaître du
paysage après avait une affirmation
pareil parce que c'était totalement du
jus de crâne c'était totalement inventés
il avait aucune preuve mais il disait
attention parce que le par mes contacts
dans les services de renseignements je
sais que c'est laid or on sait tous que
c'est totalement faux donc je reviens
sur le lobby saoudien dans le lobby
saoudien tu as aussi si tu veux ces mecs
qui sont prêts à écrire n'importe quoi
pour avoir une place dans un article
pour se présenter comme le spécialiste
quand tu regardes l'arctique vallarta
l'impression qu'ils couchent dans la
chambre à coucher à côté de poutine quoi
donc si tu veux quand tu as dans le
paysage des personnages comme ça tu te
dis c'est quoi l'intérêt de maiden de
dalida les pousser en ukraine c'est quoi
l'intérêt de maiden de
spectre assez pour répondre à la russie
qui est accusé d'avoir fait une cyber
qui attaquent les états unis c'est quoi
alors bon c'est qu'il faut savoir c'est
que quand il ya la décomposition de
l'urss bon ça se fait en plusieurs
morceaux puisqu'il ya évidemment les
pays satellites d'abord puis ensuite il
ya l'éclatement de l'urss donc les pays
satellites vont demander à entrer dans
l'otan tout de suite ce n'est pas
discuté c'est l'époque et il n'y a pas
de discussion puis ensuite quand le
l'écrêtement du rsa si l ukraine qui va
demander à re leurs alliés l'otan et là
il ya une divergence entre américains et
européens parce que les européens qui
sont parfaitement sensibles vous comment
dire allah qui connaissent mieux la
sensibilité russes disent non il vaut
mieux que l'ukraine n'entre pas dans
l'otan parce que ça voudrait dire que
l'otan serait au contact direct de la
russie et les américains disent ici il
faut que l'ukraine etc bref la
discussion s'interrompt là dessus c'est
à dire que l'ukraine ne sera pas membre
de l'otan par contre les états baltes
leçons entre etc mais l'ukraine c'était
un gros morceau et on sentait bien la
capacité de déstabilisation qu'une
entrée du crâne aurait sur l'otan donc
il ya toujours chez les américains cette
idée que l'ukraine est une pièce
maîtresse qui est une pièce maîtresse
qui pourrait éventuellement su utiliser
contre le la russie mais pour les russes
ça veut dire que c'est là comment dire
une action militaire à leurs frontières
c'est vraiment le truc si tu prends la
carte de la russie avec les états d'asie
centrale il n'y a pas de menace sud pour
eux parce qu'il ya tout cet état tampon
si tu veux que son laser by jean le le
kazakhstan et s'est donc c'est dû à la
nature de la menace est évidemment ce
passé qui a été toute la glace banque de
la guerre froide c'est quand même pour
les russes qui ont dissous le pacte de
varsovie et qui n'ont jamais obtenu la
dissolution de l'otan en parallèle il
considère que vu de leur point de vue
que il ya toujours une alliance
militaire si tu veux et si cette
influence militaire arriverez près de
leur frontière peut être regardée comme
une menace donc tu vois tout ça c'est
des domaines de perception
l'établir avec des mesures de confiance
s'est passé pas évident
spectacle d'avenir avec nos dirigeants
en france pour pouvoir apporter un peu
plus de lubrification entre les rapports
internationaux ou d'un simple mot
affaire à une caste planqué au quai
d'orsay sélectionnés par des hautes
études coopté je te passe je te passe la
fin du raisonnement et où on va
continuer à faire perdurer ce petit
système en attendant que ça se passe
d'abord il faut quand même se dire
qu'une administration ca besoin de
cadres
quand même je veux dire c'est pas le
triomphe delà de l'ignorance qui va nous
assurer d'être un peu plus rationnel non
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est la
sociologie dans des organisations c'est
à dire que le la république française
est une république si tu veux qui a
fonctionné après 45 comme la fabrication
républicaine des élites ça va être le
recrutement des hauts fonctionnaires par
l'ena ça va être les grands corps que
constitue centrale les mines etc etc
ces élites si tu veux on fait la
reconstruction de la france après guerre
si la france est aujourd'hui cinquième
ou sixième puissance de la planète c'est
aussi parce que il ya si tu veux cette
espèce de d comment dire de dévouement à
l'intérêt public dont étaient porteurs
un certain nombre de ces de ses élites
là où le système se pervertit c'est que
si c'est un système si tu veux de
sélection strictement universitaire
prend un exemple d'une trajectoire d'un
homme que je connais bien mais si tu
veux
tu fais classe prépa
normale sup sciences po ena grand corps
cabinet ça veut dire que pendant dix ans
de ta vie tu n'as pas toucher terre tu
as été un pur produit du système
universitaire français
et ça ça veut dire que tu ne connais pas
le monde t'a jamais eu une année
sabbatique ou tu t'es dit je vais
prendre mon sac à dos je vais aller
découvrir le monde tu vois ce que je
veux dire moi et donc ça ça génère une
philosophie qui n'est jamais explicite
mais qui est qui et après en na'vi
évidente c'est la france et la terre est
plate et la france en est le centre et
c'est pareil aux états unis un jeune
ayant pour intérêt plateau si donc tu as
une machine à produire de la légitimité
le quai d'orsay en fait partie mais ce
n'est pas le seul une fois je me suis
amusé à écrire un télégramme
diplomatique sans objet c'est à dire un
télégramme diplomatique dans lequel
j'utilisais tous les argumentaires qu'un
ambassadeur doit renvoyer à paris pour
expliquer combien la vie de la france
est importante sur le pays dans le
crédit et donc le courage dit ça c'est
parce que quand tu es ambassadeur
quelque part tu vas pas expliqué au
ministre que tout le monde se fout de ce
que la france pense donc tu es obligé
d'expliquer que tu as eu des réunions
avec les autres ambassadeurs de l'union
européenne qu'on attend la position du
gouvernement français sur le sujet et
ses draps mais fondamentalement c'est
une machine à entretenir l'illusion
tu vois donc
évidemment sur le quai d'orsay c'est une
certaine tropisme qui est important mais
tu as aussi des gens de grande qualité
qui essayent à certains moments de faire
passer des idées différentes pas à bien
d'un qui va leur vision pendant qu'il
faut briser n'ont pas toujours pas
toujours parce que le système
pardon du placard pas toujours pas
toujours
bien des gens si tu veux qui par exemple
qui était ambassadeur en iran qui ont
essayé de tempérer si tu veux les
discours qui se tenait à paris sur
l'iran il ya un type qui viennent de
décéder malheureusement qui s'appelait
nicouleau qui a été le qui a été le
directeur de cabinet du ministère
défense et qui ensuite a été nommé à
téhéran et qui essayait dans ces
télégrammes de dire attention les choses
ne sont pas cette espèce de construction
qu'on fait à paris et c'est donc il a eu
une carrière mais quel a été le poids de
ce qu'ils disaient par rapport à ce qui
se disait à pareille somme question
internet avoir son avis d'expert est un
les récents que peut faire un citoyen
lambda avec ses connaissances le peuple
devrait pas ni festi contre la politique
extérieure du gouvernement pour
l'interrogation
c'est difficile parce que la politique
extérieure du gouvernement c'est
beaucoup de choses c'est à la fois la
construction de l'europe
quand même c'est fantastique c'est la
réconciliation franco allemande tu sais
que la réconciliation franco-allemande
est le seul exemple de déconstruction de
l'ennemi dans l'histoire universelle on
s'était fait trois guerres et à deux
hommes d'état qui sont de gaulle et
adenauer qui décide on arrête le match
et on construit l'europe à partir du
traité de l'élysée donc si tu veux la
politique extérieure française c'est
aussi tout ça on va pas tout jeter que
par contre on puisse estimer à certains
moments que l'utilisation de l'armée
française pour faire des opérations
militaires extérieures n'est pas
obligatoirement une bonne méthode et on
l'a bien vu dans la divergence entre
chirac et ses successeurs quand chirac
dit on faut pas faire la guerre en irak
tu avais bien à l'intérieur du système
des gens qui pensaient différemment
l'idée qu'ensuite hollande et sarkozy
allait faire exactement le contraire on
aurait pu penser qu'il avait pris il
aurait profité de cette trouée quand tu
vois la situation où bernard-henri lévy
convainc sarkozy qu'il faut aller
bombarder en libye
tu te dis là il ya quelque chose auquel
il faut s'attaquer c'est à dire ce
complexe militaro intellectuelle qui va
décider d'envoyer des militaires que la
caractéristique des militaires français
c'est qu'ils sont militarisme et sont
pas belliciste
ils savent ce que c'est que la guerre
donc ils sont pas destinés à partir la
fleur au fusil en disant on va leur
rentrer dans la par contre pas des tas
de gens qui vont décider de faire la
guerre à leur place ou en tout cas
d'expliquer pourquoi il faut faire la
guerre alors que là ça fait vendu du
livre ça fait vendre du papier ça fait
briller en société dans les salons
feutry ça fait quoi d'abord
examiner les richissimes consistance
ionisé par en détails extérieurs les
ingérences non non non non dans le cas
propre camp français si on revient sur
cette affaire de la limite si tu veux
c'est un glissement de sens qui est très
intéressant à étudier bernard henri lévy
station d'avion perso et il voit en
egypte et il va du côté de
l'insurrection libyenne sur la
parti elle y revient à voir sarkozy et
puis ils lui disent a été citée par le
point ah je les ai rencontrés ce sont
des démocrates il ya le nouveau massoud
on fait référence évidemment grands
conseillers grands prédécesseurs
illustres bas et donc sarkozy va faire
adopter aux nations unies puisqu'il ya
quand même une insurrection il ya quand
même des violences en libye une
destruction de l'onu permettant à
l'aviation française ce qu'on appelle
une interdiction de survol aérien c'est
à dire que l'aviation française devait
interdire à ça kadhafi d'utiliser ses
avions de combat france pardon mais dit
ça touche pas tous y voit aussi des
avions russes donc si tu veux le
principe c'est que ça va consister à
interdire que sarko de kadhafi utilise
sa super yachts et aériens mais qu'est
ce qui va se passer ensuite c'est que
les troupes se passe à l'est en passant
au sol va à ce moment-là courir un bruit
qui a une colonne blindée qui est en
train de se diriger vers tripoli pour
aller massacrer les insurgés donc au
lieu de faire du site d'altération de
survols aériens les français vont donner
instruction aux pilotes français
d'intervenir au sol pour arrêter la
fameuse colonne donc tu vois comment on
passe d'une situation
juridiquement assez clair à quelque
chose qui est une intervention au sol
est à partir de ce moment-là bon tu
connais le truc là y'avait pas de
colonne de chars mais en fait un parti
ce moment-là ça rétabli comment dire ça
a établi le déséquilibre militaire en
faveur des insurgés et puis cette scène
finale où kadhafi type le son palais
présidentiel et il est attrapé par une
part un barrage et donc il va être
exécuté tout de suite comme ça alors
paraît-il que tu as répondu à côté de la
question sur laquelle que peut tout
faire en tant que citoyen
moi j'ai encore une fois tous les
citoyens sont pas préoccupés par les
questions que je pose moi tout ce que je
fais c'est que j'essaye d'apporter une
expertise en les mettant à disposition
de gens qui veulent bien lire mais il ya
des tas de gens qui sont pas d'accord
avec moi quand j'ai sorti mon bouquin
sur docteur chaoulli des mr jihad j'ai
eu droit à une espèce de compte rendu
absolument incendiaires fait par le quai
d'orsay sur mon bouquin en expliquant
que j'étais saoudo fob alors j'ai
répondu que je croyais que c'était
d'être saoudo fils qui était un problème
mais non visiblement tu as à l'intérieur
du site des gens et si tu veux qu'ils
sont prêts à défendre des positions
informe indéformable et parce qu'ils
sont pris dans un système tu cherches le
type auquel il avait confié la lecture
de mon bouquin c'était le représentant
français à l'organisation de la
coopération islamique tu vois c'est à
dire on ne pouvait pas trouver un
individu objectif que celui là est donc
tu te dis ya à l'intérieur du système
des gens qui prétendent que pour la
légitimité de leur carrière pour leur
avancement et c'est que le ministre se
comporte donc je ne sais pas moi je peux
pas faire plus que ce que je fais c'est
à dire j'essaye d'apporter de
l'information des analyses mais tout ce
que je peux conseiller à ce monsieur
c'est de lire beaucoup lire participer à
des discussions
éventuellement intervenir dans les
débats où il a quelques éléments
apportés manifesté à deir et faire de la
politique
c'est tout ce que je peux dire moi je
n'ai pas de solution et s'il vous plaît
je suis
la question internet pourquoi la france
c'était laisser humilier par la turquie
à plusieurs reprises pourquoi la france
n'a rien fait pour 12 à guy kurdes
deux questions différentes bon
l'humiliation évidemment l'humiliation
c'est un thème important tu sais que
dans tout nationalisme ya toujours
l'idée qu' il faut se venger de cette
humiliation de ses rangs les
humiliations avec la entre la france et
la turquie bon il ya
l'espèce de delirium tremens qui est
celui des rohan qui considèrent que les
musulmans sont maltraités en france et
c'est clairement le même individu qui va
transformer sainte-sophie en mosquée tu
vois donc tu vois bien ce que je te
disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire il ya
une double identité turquie à les
héritiers d'atatürk qui en avait fait un
musée et puis cette identité islamique
dont verdone veut se présenter comme le
nouveau leader si tu veux du cynisme
combattants donc entendre les turcs
expliqué qu'effectivement la faune
musulmans sont maltraités en france tu
sais en france on aime bien des français
de culture musulmane qui dénonce la
radicalisation qui dénoncèrent doan et
c'est donc l'humiliation c'est un débat
entre un chef d'état qui est son projet
idéologique cette espèce d'islam
politique qui va essayer de défendre qui
va d'ailleurs essayé de perturber aussi
les pays arabes puisque lui-même n'étant
pas un marabout si tu venais tant que
turc sa légitimité religieuse est
difficile à construire donc donc ces
tueurs encore une fois le personnage
qu'il faut le prendre pour ce qu'il est
il a cette caractéristique que
effectivement étant donné qu'on est allé
faire ses glorieuses conflits en irak et
en syrie là sous le flot des réfugiés
qui évidemment encore une fois ne part
pas vers l'arabie saoudite on se demande
pourquoi partent vers l'europe et donc
ils sont obligés de passer par à travers
la turquie et donc les turcs qui sont
pris dans une ambiguïté soit il les a il
intercepte mais dans ce cas là ça veut
dire c'est eux qui doivent entretenir le
flou des réfugiés soit il délaisse pas
ses six a été le cas pendant longtemps
et donc jusqu'à ce qu'on négocie avec
ardoines l'idée qu'il puisse retenir sur
son territoire des flots de réfugiés
mais il a les cartes maîtresses en mer
douanes livre attendez moi les réfugiés
c'est pas moi qui les ai créé c'est vous
d'abord et puis ensuite si vous les
voulez pas vous devez payer bon donc il
faut faire attention bien on lui demande
un service pour lequel on va
effectivement lui verser d'argent mais
en fait en même temps le jour où ils
décident de plus respectée le truc ça
veut dire que la masse des réfugiés qui
sont sur le territoire touché plus
combien ils sont aujourd'hui 1 ou 2
millions se veut peuvent très bien d'un
seul coup rentrer sur le territoire
européen avec la fragilité de la grèce
de l'est de la bulgarie 3-1 canard ben
si tu veux c'est encore une fois c'est
les conséquences politiques indirectes
de cette volonté de militariser toutes
les relations internationales ensuite
nos alliés kurdes les premiers à les
avoir trahis les cures de ces américains
c'est eux qui ont décidé de les
abandonner mais les kurdes c'est pas la
première fois dans l'histoire qu'ont les
trahit il avait droit à un état après
des négociations de versailles quand
atatürk décide de réduire le kurdistan
va les voir repartir en conflit pour
défendre les kurdes là-bas donc les
pauvres kurdes y sont habitués à ça
enfin ils sont habitués sont pas encore
habitués mais ils sont malheureusement
toujours les victimes de tout ça
et encore une fois contre l'opinion
publique comprendre est telle qu'on
envoie un contingent se battre déjà sur
l'irak s'est imposée problème est qu'on
envoie d'aidé du combattant se battent
au kurdistan donc
pour moi c'est pas ce n'est pas un fait
négligeable que de dire ont déclenché
une guerre et dernière remarque que je
te disais tout à l'heure
la turquie verdone veut absolument
garder le contrôle de ces turcs migrants
migrer émigré en occident et
l'organisation qu'ils ont adoptée qui
dépend donc du ministère des affaires
religieuses c'est pour garder le
contrôle de ces turcs émigrés donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya une espèce de
l'identité turque eu ici plus d'ailleurs
plutôt en allemagne qu'en france mais
qui est importante en france et qui
encore une fois ne veut pas obéir aux
règles de la république française donc
est ce que tu fais une guerre en te
disant que tu as sur le territoire
français 600000 mec dont tu ne connais
pas les comment dire la rue le
républicanisme
je peux aller pisser un peu là attend
juste ligue derrière jusqu'à 9 h marche
tout lâche quand on balance
qui ne laissera pas à l'interview
je cause je cause donc je me dépêche
quant au canton balanceront toute chose
sur l'arabie séoudite des toupes a
menacé personnellement n'avez-vous
jamais eu de problèmes par rapport à vos
livres et propos avez-vous peur des
saoudiens ya que moi qui vais pisser
gardons ici et que moi qui vais pisser
oui mais justement tu laisses la roma le
rang hiérarchique
non je crois que si tu veux
bon les saoudiens si tu veux c'est pas
c'est pas des foudres de guerre ils vont
pas venir et ils vont aller
effectivement décomposé en morceaux en
opposant sur le mandat du régime avec
l'entourage du prince etc ça
effectivement il existe hymne que c'est
de leur légitimité mais avec la
maladresse qui a révélé l affaire
khashoggi c'est à dire que is here
prétend pas il ne se firent colons pas
une nouvelle fois et encore une fois
c'était pas citoyens que considéré comme
saoudiens ont
assassiné des mecs à l'étranger c'est
pas leur truc ça c'est le plus tôt les
trucs des salafistes que d'assassiner
des mecs des musulmans mer encore une
fois on est dans une idéologie dans
lequel la cible principale qui vaut la
peine d'être exécutée à l'étranger c'est
le traître alors le traite ça peut être
le mauvais croyant ça pouvait être le
mec de la religion dominante mais qui
dénonce si tu veux les excès de ce truc
c'est par exemple tu vois avec le
quand ces français le collectif contre
l'islamophobie en france cette
organisation est née grosso modo en
2002-2003 si tu veux et donc va se bédié
a dénoncé les actes islamophobes en
france ment comme il n'arrivait pas à en
trouver il a construit 10 par une
politique une
stratégie judiciaire ça veut dire qu'à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un journaliste
un avocat qui dénonçait les dérives de
l'islam etc il faisait un programme un
truc en diffamation pour islamophobie la
plupart du temps il perdait donc et une
dizaine de journalistes qui ont eu droit
à ce genre de procès mais à chaque fois
ils perdent et puisqu'il l'islamophobie
n'existe pas dans le droit français le
blasphème n'existe pas bon comme cette
stratégie n'a pas marché mais ça a eu
davantage d'inscrire le terme
d'islamophobie dans le débat politique
être à bout qui a donné un conseil pour
les jeunes générations un pardon by
pacte à trois après pisser fait mauvais
tu t'attends contient trois bouquins un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
avant de partir je termine sur
l'islamophobie quand ensuite ça n'a pas
marché ils ont inventé un concept qui
est très intéressant qui s'appelle
l'islamophobie d'état l'intérêt de
l'islamophobie d'état c'est que personne
ne te répond on y est l'état et
islamophobe qui va répondre d'abord il
en panne n'apporte pas de preuve alors
ils ont une technique et assez
astucieuse moi j'ai eu à entrer en
contact avec eux quand j'écrivais un
rapport sur la contrée radicalisation
2014 j'appelle donc le collectif contre
l'islamophobie je tombe sur la porte
parole qui écument convertis et l'orge
dit voilà je travaille sur la
radicalisation je voudrais on peut
connaître votre point de vue elle me dit
ah non non nous ça ne nous concerne pas
seul nous concerne les actes
islamophobes
fumer vous appelez islamophobe elle me
dit à chaque fois qu'il ya un an qu'on
nous signale un acte un comportement
islamophobe etc j'ai dit c'est marrant
quand je parle avec vous j'ai
l'impression de parler que le crif alors
sais pas pourquoi il ya une minute de
silence si tu veux et je lui ai dit mais
le jour où vous avez un musulman radical
et un juif intégré ce qui se tape sur la
gueule comment fait-on c'est
l'islamophobie et de l'antisémitisme
je sais pas pourquoi elle a raccroché
donc si tu veux c'était un truc qui se
dédient et qu'à une seule chose
construit sur des statistiques qui n'ont
jamais été vérifiées par personne disant
qu' il y avait que des actes
islamophobes en france tu as des
observatoires sur les actes de
radicalisme d'islamophobie etc mais
jamais les chiffres ne correspondait
donc au bout d'un certain temps leurs
chiffres et en deux complètement
surréaliste ils ont arrêté de publier
des chiffres et à partir de ce moment
ils ont internationaliser leur cause
c'est à dire sont allés en turquie pour
expliquer combien la france était
islamophobe et c est donc tu as
aujourd'hui une assemblée de pays qui
respectent pas plus les droits de
l'homme que l'arabie saoudite et qui
accuse la france d'être islamophobe où
tu vas voir les pakistanais sinon je
savais même pas où se trouve la france
tu veux avoir les turcs qui va voir des
gens comme ça qui accuse la france
d'être islamophobe dans une certaine
mesure ce collectif qui est une espèce
d'hypocrisie extraordinaire avait réussi
à introduire ce terme de l'islamophobie
dans le débat politique français ça n'a
jamais ils voulaient alors la dernière
étape celle ci avant leur dissolution
ç'aurait été que ce soit inscrit dans le
droit français comme l'antisémitisme à
ce moment là effectivement il aurait
réussi leurs frères bon manque de chance
la dissolution est venue frapper un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
trois livres
je vous conseillerais bien trois des
miens mais c'est sur un peu excessif
alors à temps parce que qu'est ce que
j'ai lu de remarquables ces derniers
temps
tu aurais dû me demander de préparer
c'est un peu avant
il ya un bouquin très vieux bouquins de
braudel
donc tu vois ça remonte à loin qu'ils
s'appellent l'identité de la france
c'est un gros bouquin à trois quand même
enfin c'est intéressant parce que c'est
la réflexion d'un historien donc il ya
l'épaisseur de la connaissance
historique et qui déjà dans les années
70-80 peu de temps avant son décès
s'étonner de la comment dire de
l'islamisation de sociétés françaises
dans ce 17 janvier ce mec est un
historien avec cette épaisseur là c'est
quand même quelque chose d'assez
étonnant
deuxième bouquin
ben il faut lire les il faut lire les
bouquins si tu veux des gens qui encore
une fois sont en face c'est à dire ceux
qui vont pour comprendre comment l'autre
fonctionne
bien bouquin de qaradawi qui était un
prédicateur
saoudien mais réfugiée en émirat arabes
unis et que souvent le cfcm invité en
france
et qui s'appelle le licite et l'illicite
bon c'est le livre pas intéressant c'est
une sorte d'interdît mais ça démontre
bien combien les radicalisme religieux
gère la vie quotidienne de tous les
croyants qui veulent bien adhérer c'est
à dire c'est le principe même de tous
les totalitarismes c'est que le
totalitarisme c'est le comment dire
c'est la réglementation la régie de tous
les actes de la vie quotidienne donc le
seul fait que le bouquin s'appelle le
licite et l'illicite t'explique comment
il faut que tu ailles chercher si jamais
tu pet de travers pour savoir si c'était
un pays à la loupe à el al
il ya un troisième bouquin peut-être que
encore une fois je me reproche je
cherche un peu mais il ya un des grands
anciens qui lequel bouquin de benda sur
la trahison des clercs de bandar ben
dhia sur la trahison des clercs pourquoi
parce que justement
il faisait 1 l'audit de quelque chose
que moi je trouve particulièrement
convaincant c'est à dire la trahison des
intellectuels français
pourquoi parce que justement on revient
à ce que je disais c'est à dire
intellectuelle c'est un homme qui voit
le monde à travers son idéologie or
rappelle toi que l'entre-deux-guerres et
même après la façon dont nos
intellectuels français se sont adhérer à
des grandes idéologies totalitaires que
ce soit le fascisme le communisme et le
communisme ça a duré pendant longtemps
considéré que sartre était le grand
penseur de la france et on va lui donner
le prix nobel alors que tu avec un must
have et aaron mais cela était
considèrent comme des traîtres tu vois
le alors que camus plaidé pour
l'équilibré tu sais quand il dit la
halle sur l'algérie entre mamer et le le
pays je choisirais ma mère il expliqué
toute la difficulté d'être un homme bon
mais c'était considéré comme il y avait
un bouquin sur albert camus comme
philosophe pour les classes terminales
tu vois c'est à dire on le méprise et
alors tu t'aperçois que ce qui reste de
sartre en fait ce qui reste de sartre et
simone de beauvoir tu voi étonnant donc
je te dis il ya des bouquins comme ça
mais je suis désolé j'ai pas réfléchi
bon conseil pour les jeunes générations
garder la tête froide garder la tête
froide parce qu'effectivement
voter selon vous vos pass aimé garder
ouvert la discussion avec l'autre faire
l'existence de l'autre
comment il reçoit la chose voyager
voyager voyager voyager voyager
non je sais mais enfin bon dès que ce
sera fini jeudi en voyage et quand on
pense que george bush devient président
des états unis alors qu'il est allé une
fois au mexique quand il était en fin de
ses études
mais je pense pas que macron ce soit
fondamentalement différent je pense pas
que étant donné la rapidité de sa
trajectoire universités ans il a eu
beaucoup le temps d'aller poser ses
guêtres en afghanistan en sicile en
grèce en libye etc tu vois ce que je
veux dire et ça c'est le principalement
que moi j'ai toujours la suppression de
l'état n'est qu'une demi mesure il faut
imposer à tous ces élites d'avoir une
année sabbatique et pendant cette année
sabbatique les mecs doivent montrer
qu'ils ont un passeport tamponné par
trois ou quatre visent à toi je sais que
c'est dur à imposer comme règle mais moi
j'avais dit ça aux américains ils
m'avaient invité une fondation
américaine aux états unis et donc on
avait eu des entretiens au pentagone à
la maison blanche etc et à la fin il
m'avait dit c'était l'époque de bush il
m'avait dit bon qu'est-ce que vous avez
tiré de votre visite aux états unis
formidable des interlocuteurs
remarquablement intelligent moi si j'ai
un conseil à vous donner c'est la
prochaine fois qu'il ya une
présidentielle chez vous exigez que tous
les candidats et un passeport usagers
avec au moins trois visages différents
ils comprenaient pas toujours pas trop
près tout de suite si tu veux que je
leur disais mais en même temps tu vois
bien qu'ils jouaient le fonction
d'attraction des élites européennes mais
que l' inverse si tu veux n'était pas
évidente pourquoi pire que l'esa merci
maman merci à vous
[Musique]